vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'ils derrière la
console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast l'intro le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
date située contre moi dom plantes
oubliées aujourd'hui les podcasts et
commanditée par kiss me design nos bons
charmed échiquier ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il commandite puis on
les aime beaucoup
c'est fondé en 2007 un projet
d'université de deux beaucerons puis
maintenant seize employés ça va vraiment
bien leur affaire il faut des années de
fabrication d'étuis cellulaire de sites
haut de gamme sont vraiment un beau
piano pour tous les goûts tous les soirs
des design vraiment beaucoup de choix
sur leur site puis toutes les sortes de
téléphones ou si la majorité des ventes
sont faites en ligne
justement en ce moment ça tombe très
bien c'est un produit lequel vous pouvez
encourager
sinon est aussi 250 points de vente au
québec
alors ces temps ci le séquençage rouvrir
fait que d'acheter en personne n'ose
hines ochoa jazz etcetera le site
branche corporatives sous les phares des
étuis pour votre
votre votre compagnie quoi que ce soit
il ya une branche pour ce alors il ya un
code promo sans filtre 15 pour 1 kg 10 %
de rabais sur votre commande détruits et
rachitisme et moi j'avais achetés par
gavi les feux en australie j'avais
acheté un quinze qui donnait des fonds
dans le fonds pour pau pour ce puits
lâche temps ma mère ma mère j'en ai
reparlé je le mentionnais la même si le
meilleur qu'est ce que j'aime et c'est
vraiment des banques estime tout à fait
faire ses caisses le quai sans filtre
quand un gars qui échappent son ciel
beaucoup aiment ou savait pas seul e
l'autre jour je les enlever pour une
raison x pendant trois jours mon cell
tout est gratuit ni fujian et jallet
monte f faut jamais elle enlève la [ __ ]
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps le shabbat chaque jour mon qui est
mon pied dans korek fait que mercy la
gagne de caisse mais sinon une petite
annonce en fait on a décidé avec les
récents évènements qui se passe partout
dans le monde donc moi on a réfléchi
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour redonner le plus possible
d'utiliser la tribune pour participer
dans le fond à l'effort collectif pour
l'équité sociale de tout le monde en
fait fait qu'on a décidé de quand on
allait avoir pas deux annonceurs par
podcast
on allait annoncer pour des compagnies
qui sont en fait qui ont été fondées par
des personnes issues des minorités
donc si vous êtes un entrepreneur issu
d'une minorité qui avez votre propre
compagnie écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
et si haut si vous travaillez pour une
obnl où vous avez même fonder une obnl
qui visent à lutter justement pour la
justice sociale
écrivez nous aussi puis on va choisir
parmi tous ces gens là pour offrir une
tribune gratuite en fait c'est notre
contribution
une de notre contribution qu'on veut
faire avec le podcast donc diffuser
notre tribune pour redistribuer
de cette façon on pourrait sûrement pas
promouvoir tout le monde mais c'est sûr
qu'on pourra pas pas exact mais
juste la petite contribution comme s'est
dit tout à fait sinon cette semaine sur
le poker ne sut catherine pitch et
catherine ne pas quitter participantes
occupation double qui oriente de gueule
de bois sans doute dire est-ce qu' une
personne formidable premièrement une
très belle personne au rayon de soleil
rayonnant un vrai petit rayon de soleil
qui venus aussi en fait parler surtout
de son retour en hôpital parce que
catherine est infirmière de profession
qu'elle avait des puits et passion
double messieurs de côté pour vivre la
vie incroyable d'influenceurs et puis
une bonne job ça chapeau
mais justement avec la pandémie 10e à
s'est senti interpellé par par le fait
de vouloir aller contribuer à aider
justement les bassins malade puis puis
aussi c'est à son ancienne équipe qu'il
faut qu'il parle de son retour
comment ça a été difficile aussi aussi
sa vision sur la pandémie le corps vêtu
ce puits aussi un message de prudence de
pas trop s'emballer à prendre tout le
monde dans ses bras quand même rester
garder les mesures qui sont qui sont
prescrites je pense que c'est encore
important qu'on fasse encore un effort
là-dessus même si ça nous tente de moins
de moins en moins qui fait beau et
compagnie il faut quand même faire
attention parce que c'est sérieux
oui tout à fait tout à fait fait qu'une
grosse conversation et catherine sur le
bonheur aussi plage où la joie de
partager la joie oui c'est que vous le
serez c'est vraiment une philosophie qui
est call phones puis qu'il faut se
rappeler souvent pu aussi ont aussi
questionné encore une fois se re dit que
la responsabilité dans tous les
mouvements sociaux comme en ce moment le
mouvement des récits des influenceurs
c'est ce qu'ont il faut absolument
prendre la parole ce qui est ce que
c'est le temps doux side et laisser la
place aux autres à ceux qui ont vraiment
un message à porter dès qu'on
réfléchisse à ce à voir autrement de
réponse beaucoup plus de questions mais
c'est intéressant tout à fait écouter en
une page pétrole
sur laquelle peut vous abonner il va en
plein de contenus exclusifs on va lancer
quelque chose la semaine prochaine on va
vous en parler non pas de casse la
semaine prochaine puis sinon laissez des
commentaires participer aux discussions
les cdd top up abonnez vous à nos
chances toutes les plateformes puis on
vous remercie d'être là bon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
c'est parti 4 c'est parti merci d'être
là ces malades s'est longtemps quand
même quand même ça fait longtemps que je
suis ici c'est vrai oui voilà exactement
exactement de d'infirmières influencera
infirmières
et que demain quand 4 a annoncé qu est
ce que tu te fais comme une publication
est ce que tu avais ton scrubs ou est ce
que tu dis est là le monde en ce moment
vraiment plus besoin d'infirmières que
d' influence aura j'ai trouvé ce débile
mental aurait j'ai trouvé ce fou qu'est
ce qu'y qu'est-ce qui t'a appelé parce
que je pense que quand il ya eu le gros
abritait en voyage
oui ben moi c'était avant même que tous
soient annoncés le sait vraiment au
plein milieu de caen s'arrêter annoncée
j'étais à cuba le premier lancement de
dire aux quelques vides
je pense que c'est rome qui rapatriait
tous les gens des états unis tout le
monde me criait tu dois retourner maison
qu'il a retournée maison mais moi je
savais tu vois je revenais dans deux
jours et je savais tellement pourquoi
faire le lit j'en étais paniquée puis à
cuba les gens ils savaient un poster
mais si ça puis aussitôt que je suis
revenue j'ai vu la situation puis écoute
ça m'a même pas pris deux minutes sa
maman gorille 30 secondes que je savais
que j'allais en quarantaine pendant 14
jours
de toute façon on peut l'acheter comme
creed contenu dans un trois et demi sur
le plateau jeudi où aller à l'hôpital
puis pouvoir parler du sujet de leur
puits de pouvoir moi c'est surtout à
aider aussi mes infirmières le moi je
suis retourné je passe du coq à l'âne a
dit mais j'ai encore un groupe depuis
deux ans de toutes les infirmières avec
qui je travaillais qui sont sur la même
unité puis moi dans le fond j'ai appelé
mon ancien boss puis j'ai dit le jeu
vous revenez à la même place le même
corps qui étaient deux soirs mais ton 20
30 heures semaine puis si tu peux
m'avancer je reviens 14 jours aussitôt
que la quarantaine est finie puis le 2
octobre appelée a dit tu commences dans
14 jours au fait que j'imagine ça doit
être offre parce que la situation c'est
comment parce que si on nous on entend
parler on voit les statistiques on voit
les morts on va les cas on le voit
portée on voit être temps que son vol iy
gens malades en m'obligeant
ça doit être la première soirée parce
que moi en fait je pensais que je
retournais en néphrologie parce que
c'est le gâchis mais néphrologie se
transformer en unité de positif à
symptômes graves
donc toi petit dans les hôpitaux ça
l'est vraiment été bien cadré rapidement
il y avait les unités verte qui avait
aucun qu'ovide les indigènes qui était
co vida symptômes légers puis rouge à
symptômes ses ventes
les zones froides exactement c'est sûr
dépendamment comment que le centre
hospitalier l'appel mais bref il y avait
ces trois là puis moi ils m'ont annoncé
deux jours plus tard les infirmiers avec
qui je travaille on vient d'avoir un
communiqué on veut devenir aux bouches
comme je sais qui je plonge dans le
cadre de l'appui au début j'avais
vraiment alarmant et si on pensait que
n'importe qui pouvait décider de tout
peuple si c'était presque comme dans un
film le dit penser que quand serait
entré dans la pièce tu l'avais petit
décédé at-on vraiment à l'armée donc
c'est soit que je suis plus allé de
reculons mais c'était impossible d'agir
ton pot mais si j'te mentirais si je
dirais les trois premiers soir j'étais à
jobs jean mane emploi est un peu pareil
lost et paul milieux de santé est
positif ou est ce qu'on essaie de
soigner les gens qui repartent le qui au
début on savait pas trop comment les
traiter on n'avait pas de connaissance
en convieront n'avait pas de
connaissance tanks / marc est courageuse
de commandes traitées d'un coiffeur on
entendait plein d'informations on essaie
de s'adapter mais au début c'était
beaucoup plus lourd pour nous de autant
pas être capable d'aider les gens
publient gens avaient peur de mourir en
voyant leur corps qui on savait comme on
voulait les rats souris mais nous on
n'avait pas favorite avait pas
d'information pour les rassurer non plus
loin non on avait juste on avait toutes
les informations de décès parlement
toutes mes patients et cgu d'egypte à de
mourir le plus normalement jeudi
quand je lis et idy valence et voyantes
et meilen elles subissent lance le haut
des bulles de s'adapter à cela puis nous
même d'avoir peur autant et c'était la
panique le moi j'ai appelé mon autre
chemin en pleurant minuit j'appelle ma
mère en pleurs amis
lui même en déniche je me suis repris
puis le gacci retourne principalement
pour désinformer pour semer le positif
pour delhaize group gagne tu voyais al
henchir là tout le temps tu si toutes
les aventures demandé de sourire est sud
est revenu car non oui au final ça sa
agité sas et tranquilliser et ça c'est
donc le avec lui je suis vraiment
vraiment content d'être retourné puis
c'est mieux
ces bêtises et au début utile on savait
pas quoi face à peu comment aider les
gens comment les traiter mais ce qu'on
ne sait vraiment plus dans le sens qui
en ce moment à ce que je sache ce n'est
pas vraiment de médicaments qui
fonctionne n'est pas prochain vaccin fac
tu es quelqu'un la planète et critiquer
ce que vous pouvez faire
ben écoute il ya vraiment c'est alice
notamment que pilote chevaux médecin
nommé
c'est hallucinant comment quand j'ai vu
les conduites à venir changer dit que
lorsqu'on fait comme contrôler la
température sitôt qu'il les met en
position ventrale aussitôt kid et sature
t il donné des tylenol pour contrôler la
fiev c'est tout des affaires très très
basique mais que si le passé ensuite
toutes les consignes qu'on est capable
parce que maintenant il ya des patients
qui sont pas capables d'être en position
ventrale mais ça c'est ce qui a aidé le
plus l'eau c'est hallucinant
un patient qui des statures par exemple
n'y a pas beaucoup d'oxygène dans son
simple qui des ceintures à 70 peut
facilement remonter à 80,18 grâce à ce
don qu'a passion de la séance suivante
simplement parce que pilou c'est ce que
j'ai entendu dire mais c'est la pression
des doudounes qui a vu que ce soit le
voit la tension d'orsay j'essaie
d'expliquer aux gars qui donnent une
pression sont les poumons donc les sauts
de ressorts plus facilement mais je seul
mes patients qui décèdent durant 72
c'est maintenant et ont toutes des 17 en
permanence à moi je le vois sur mon
tableau pisi lui peut se mettre en
position ventrale
je veux le voir puis jeudi mettez vos
impôts si on notera ici y passe les lits
délai par exemple s'il a créé souvent
c'est quoi ces deux trois jours s'ils
passent possiblement qui va vraiment
bien s'en remettre ça avec claire kim
avoir passé le pays non pas que c'est
vraiment la saturation que la
température puis le pouls que nous on
checke le plus en tant qu'infirmière
mais au début on ne savait même pas la
position ventrale mais quand qu'on le su
quand moi je
rappel il ya une hymne à l'eau qui me
disait mail en position ventrale puis on
savait même pas si le patient allait
s'en sortir position ventrale poux il ya
bien saturées et puis tant qu'on ne
contrôle et ce il s'en est remis en fait
je dis pas que c'est me rahho que mais
je dis que c'est il ya comme quand même
des candidats n'est vraiment clair pour
aider à s'en sortir
moi même ma soeur et ophtalmo puis à
l'été est en résidence en fait qu'elles
étaient affectées les tâches que vident
et où est-ce qu'ils travaillent puis ce
que tu décris de l'espèce de nankin
essence de caisse qui sans rien espèce
de lance dans le vide en sachant pas
trop elle a le vécu ça en rentrant dans
le manque évident le poète était pas
formés pour ça a été formé pour les yeux
tir puis le c'est ok tu entends parler
en italie kiki du monde pour les
ventilateurs pilotes face tu vois les
lie le monde se remplir plutôt qu'une
idée c'est quand même et c'est quand
même un tour du sancy ouais ouais non
vraiment vraiment au début et je ne sais
même pas comment décrire c'est qu'on
savait rien fait que justement on se
protège et un malade métier j'aime bien
aussi ce temps là où est ce que la
population ne craignait plus loin sur le
genre de voir les chiffres parce que le
c'est l'été il fait beau on veut un
guide ont aimé - jeu la première qui va
aller dans un bar avec mizan non
historien qui veut mais on ne peut pas
pis ça il faut que les gens comprennent
cgem du hall k vide existe plus août il
ya des statistiques qui montrent de ce
que j'ai vu et que cette année il ya eu
autant de décès que les années passées
au total un pays qui me disent que ça
existe pas mais divorce à l'italie puis
la chine qui osent et technique est ça
existe pas bougé moi j'avais vu le
chiffre inverse la sécurité catherine
fourni contre celui-ci a le procédé à
cette date ici au québec normalement y
attendait ses acquis rien de temps de
plus puis c'est exactement presque
exactement deux chiffres eux voudraient
vérifier officiellement et c'est une
autre affaire le ciel
la mauvaise information mais qui est
partagé puis les tableaux tellement
mentor de commenter les jacks 10 voici
dans les derniers 2 mois les morts de la
route les morts du cancer les mordus
coville
évidemment les modes que viennent sont
moins élevés que tu es sauf que ce parce
que on prend les plus grandes mesures
qui ont jamais des priorités c'est comme
si on prenait des mesures aussi
drastiques pour les voitures
ces personnes qui roulent la colifata
raide quand tu roules à cinq km heure en
haut de la limite c'est comme si on
prenait des mesures aussi drastiques
c'est sûr que la chef diminuerait moi ce
qui me fâche et les gens qui disent ah
oui mais c'est juste de 1000 personnes
c'est juste des personnes âgées mais ces
deux mille personnes qui serait pas
décédé
faut-il aussi les ch et celle des mais
les agents à aider les gens se portaient
très bien il allait bien il vivait avec
des jeunes et envoyer leurs
petits-enfants dont 20 passés les gens
qui disent oh mais c'est juste 2004 mire
mais ces quatre kits est pas opposé il
serait mort entre non mais non mais non
mais non voyons voyons deux sets 6-2 5-7
agrément rtc les gens qui n'ont pas eu
personne autour d'eux qu'ils sont cons
qui ont été affectés du cohabitent donc
ils pensent que ça existe pas cessé la
problématique si l'observation ypsilon
la deuxième vague
weiss selon - ouais donc tout
l'impression qu'on sait des conflits un
petit peu trop vite avec l'arrivée du on
le sentira switch le deux semaines après
la fin avril ça comme ça mais j'y
comprend légende et année et puis les
gens ont vraiment bien fait dit le
confinement était incroyablement bien et
qu'on rit puis les gens suivent les
consignes de ce que j'ai vu tj polynésie
gip a vu deux mais c'est que l'eau sont
année puis j'ai hâte de voir dès cet été
des justes d'un parc lalla la limite de
2 ma été les épiceries dessus des
infections encore des trucs parce qu'il
faut que tu le fais c'est sûr que c'est
sûr qu'ils aient un rallongement c'est
parce que je pense pas que tu peux
demander à une société est maintenant
qu'on prend ce de façon plus mac roll
tué je pense que tu peux demander une
société de rester aussi disciplinés
pendant aussi longtemps j'ai pas
l'impression que l'être humain peut
fonctionner de cette façon
mais en même temps je sais quoi l'autre
option c'est ce souci car ce moment tu
ici tout le temps un bal en du pour et
du contre tc évidemment que si on se dit
qu'on finit voir plus de cas mais toutes
les dommage collatéral du dico vide tai
chi et qui jettent l anxiété le tri
problèmes psychologiques peuvent être
liés à ce petit problème économique
aussi fait j'essaie faut faire attention
quelconque on parle dès que j'ai mis mes
métiers mettant quelqu'un qui qui serait
déjà une position vraiment vulnérable
ça peut être justement les victimes
collatérales du café de temps la voix
directement avec bref je pense qu'ils et
puis même la santé publique ont une
petite hutte et à jongler avec ceux de
tickets ce conte qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ça parce que s'ils ont des confins
de paulhe arrive ce sont des compagnies
arrivent ce qu'est ce qu'ils n'appuient
pas seulement c'est ce métier moi
j'aimerais juste que les gens y pensent
à leurs parents s'ils vivent avec leurs
parents s'ils vivent avec leurs grands
parents si vous le faites pas pour vous
faites le pour eux parce que tu es jeudi
une génération on a vraiment
l'impression de vingt six minutes par ce
même mois thé je vous ai vu que j paul
couvy depuis que ça fait deux mois que
je jouais avec des patients qui ont
commis depuis que je protège et je me
dis ans et surgelés ou pitchent
immunisés et une pensée magique de jeu
larry pope jeu va être correct mais
c'est cette pensée locke qui est
dangereuse puis si vous le faites pas
pour vous fêtez pour vos parents parce
que lui même fait lit pour la deuxième
vague parce que le jeune longtemps que
tu peux voir dix personnes à deux mètres
puis sérieusement ça c'est super le fun
mais si les chiffres doublent trépy
quadruples
ben ils vont remettre en confinement
mais le stade c'est ça qu'il mesure
drastique pas que vous avez la chance
d'avoir un été avec dix personnes à 2 m
s et à l'extérieur
essayez de le respecter et d'un sens
aller dans une colo même et fait un feu
soit ya deux mecs parce que est ce que
vous préférez ça ou rien parce que c'est
sûr que si ça empire et empire et empire
le confinement voire koné puis on était
dans un trois et demi sous le plateau
est un peu plus basse et c'est ça qui
est marrant c'est ce que
c'est ce qui me rend le plus incertain
pic imf est possiblement le plus peur
c'est que les gens fassent ailleurs
qu'il ça descend la courbe des sens et
good
mais c'est comme tout les effets du
titre que les effets de confinement
qu'on parle en ce moment là si ça repart
de l'autre côté là ça va être deux fois
pire toutes les effets sur l'économie
sur la santé mentale
admettons que le ca est en béton comme
dit l'hiver prochain est ou à l'automne
on retourne en confirmant cette fois
long on le garde
est ce ce seul ce ça va faire capoter
tout le monde c'est long de quoi onu
méthode de confinement loup l onu deux
mois et demi maintenant de confinement
ou est ce que c'était que pour rester là
les deux mois et demi c'est vraiment pas
si longue sud c'est dans l'échelle du
truc le sait pas si long que puis si on
retourne le sait et on profite de l'été
si ça rapport à l'automne
ça va pas être deux mois et demi puis ça
va pas être luz ne puisse se fait pas
deux comme dirait tout et tout le monde
qui ont besoin leur semaine dans le sud
l'hiver tout le monde qui ont besoin de
faire du ski mais juste les parties de
noël les partenaires aux jeunes familles
parce que c'est que si ça repart la
deuxième wagon services est tombé
directement dans ce temps là oui moi
c'est ce qui me fait peur c'est ce qui
me fait papy c'est maintenant on voit
justement c'est en ce moment c'est sûr
que ce qui se passe aux etats-unis remet
en perspective
plusieurs choses dans le monde dans
société
mais de tes devoirs des manifestations
c'est à la fois vraiment beau mais à la
fois extrêmement anxiogènes pour moi
mettons le thé surtout qu'on sait c'est
moi c'est l'image des des manifs
armorial qui s'est passé dernièrement
puis évidemment tout le monde essaie de
rester distancié avec un masque mais on
s'entend que l on met mettez vous un
masque - les fautes
c'est une personne sort du pas de masse
gens
c'est super beau j'encourage c'est
parfait c'est le fun mais justement en
ce moment avec la pandémie mondiale
minimalement mais pas de masque alerter
les instances bouger tel sur place puis
la grande majorité du monde avec des
masques mais par contre y'a t'il et j'en
garde une distance mais je n'ai pas de
telles manifestations gad elmaleh en
place - mais ce qui me créais le plus
d'anxiété dans ces images là c'était que
t'es pas t'es pas à québec ces plaines
d'abraham moi ce que tout le monde prend
2 m
tout le monde est en amp lt tu es dans
l'épicentre canadien de l'aco vide
d'antan puis les mesures sont pas
respectées estime aussi ses seuls était
potes et pas dans une région est ce
qu'il n'ya pas de covington en place
ou est-ce qu'il y en a le plus leurs
causes dans leur taille plus qu'une
cellule accueillir le problème parce que
je les comprends aussi tout à fait j'ai
pour toi je te dis que ça remet en
perspective de la forme est 5e et moi le
but allemand à l'hôpital on en parle on
est stressé pied on se dit ça va être
quoi les prochains jours donc 1 6 6 2
ces deux c'est l'inversé qu'il faut
faire pour que ça marche il reste que
les images sont frappantes
alors que alors que pendant des mois et
des mois tu te faisais du rire ben tu te
fait dire à et distanciation tu vois
tout le monde à tout le monde en parle
qui sont à cinq mètres de différence que
personne sur le plateau puis l'image d'
adresser des regroupements mondiaux à
travers le monde c'est comme ça mais
mais mais justement ce déconfinement le
tir progressif confiance maman est ce
que est ce que tu as des premières
lignes sans l'effet ou parce que quand
on regarde justement les stars ça chaque
jour nombre d'essais nombre d'éco semble
en baisse encore tout s'assemble
y aller parce que tu as ressenti un
espèce de haut qui tout d'un coup il y
avait plus de monde qui rentrent mais
moi je dirais que c'est toujours de
signer en 2005
c'est comme pas mal plus ardue semaine
n'étant que la personne qui est allé en
ville c'est pour laver les mains à vue
les a mis dans sa bouche est porteur est
allé voir sa grand messe en hommage leur
soit tu es je veux des facs chéserex que
puisque c'est très très dramatique l'eau
comme scénario bien je crois mais je
suis pas comme si c'était comme si
c'était hors des hordes hors d'une
possibilité ce que tu viens de dire le
système est possible avec moi tout ce
que j'espère c'est juste prenez les
mesures parce que jamais jamais jamais
jamais que je vais leur dire ne faites
pas ça parce que l'on ce moment je pense
qu'il ya eu un magnifique mouvement qui
se fait autour de ce que je dois et fé
mais ces dons ben tocci qui soit en même
temps qui ne parle pas de cela c'est la
merde
j'entendais j'écoutais un podcast qui
c'est un expert de la santé publique qui
parlait qui disait que on va en
apprendre énormément sur le virus dans
les prochaines semaines suite à ce qui
se passe en ce moment dit avant
d'apprendre grandement sur le taux de
viralité sur un qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce virus là dans des températures
chaudes
comment est-ce qu'on gère ce qu'ils
disent on va la prendre mal à prendre
vraiment beaucoup dans les prochaines
semaines parce que le monde se sont
regroupés fait que dans les prochains
deux semaines on va savoir vraiment plus
ce qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce vilain
mais j'aimerais tout ce qui est dans le
meilleur des mondes
et ça continue à 200
c'est vraiment incroyable mais le coach
avant tandis que tu as vu plus de décès
dans les dix semaines de travail dans le
vide que toutes les années des formules
que tu as fait avant je lis fuyait les
personnes décédées nommé rni qui sont
super bonne fille qui ils voient ça
comme une grande preuve de respect des
clauses dans les derniers moments puis
c'est de s'occuper de la personne
décédée
non moi j'ai les accompagnent c'est ce
exactement moi c'est ça mais voir un
corps sans vie qui me semble être
quelqu'un de très sensible les gens très
émotive et empathique ça doit être dur
de fret infirmière qui d'être aussi je
te connais pas donc sommé joly était
vraiment apathique
ouais mais vient un moment où est ce que
justement ce qui en pratique plutôt
sympathique puis je pense que j'arrive
vraiment à m cm mais c'est off parce que
des fois tu t'attaches à des patients le
moi je l'appelle micro qui est là il ya
un an que tu bandes tellement victime
étant moins moi quand je me mets est
proche d'un patient le ma passion
séduite et si vous si vous qui avez 70
81 aviez la possibilité de vous voir
rentrer à 25 m quels conseils vous
donneriez à vous même pour les
prochaines années
ah et puis j'entends d'exotique parce
que c'est le fun les raisons en ce
moment mais j'aimerais dont ceux qui a
aiguisé influenceurs de 80 90 ans parce
que il pourrait ou non mais savait
exactement ce serait beaucoup mieux
parce qu'il aurait vécu témoin comme une
fois j'ai entendu changerait rien ma vie
a été par faire la paix la phacélie
regrets comme une fois j'ai entendu à
priorité c'est la mode toujours plus
d'amour d'amour on a tous le même envers
ceux qui te déteste de la mode donne
dans mon jeu j'ai entendu tellement d'un
message que j pris dans mon bagage que
maintenant j'essaie d'apporter dans ma
vie que je trouve ça beau à prendre soin
d'eux même si j'essaie pour en revenir à
ta question même si j'essaie de ne pas
m'attacher quand je veux pas un humain
en bande avec des des patients donc
c'est difficile quand c'est une petite
voix qui vont moins bien mais faut pas
parce qu'il faut que ce soit toutes
égales
traite également du cepii on le sait dès
fois on dit mettons le patient x soit
qui ait décidé soit qui est partie chez
lui mon île on est tous unanimes sur le
fait que lui seul sait comment on s'en
parle entre nous puis on a l'équipe le
mois ci s'était pas de l'équipe serait
possiblement peut-être peau retournée
je devrai que le numéro un ça a été les
filles se peignaient ts orifices à
plagne ats les faits d excellents enfin
il y avait le corvaisier tendancieuses
s'écouter sauter temps supplémentaire
obligatoire supplémentaire que fakhir en
avait plein puis le les filles commente
s le groupe commente s le groupe gt
comme je peux pas en douter du travail
chez nous pis les regarder dans ce
groupe le rocher puis pas y retourner
non moi j'y suis retourné puis comme le
je travaille à 16 heures ce soir puis
j'ai vraiment 3 d'aller les voir c'est
tout à ton âge tu planifierait le encore
combien de temps ce qui trie sur baïse
logis écoute moi je fonctionne à projets
la salle aucun sens que j'en ai 18 ans
ce moment précis qui se rendront pas de
lyon très en beauté un lit c'est josé
mais j'ai goût de rester mais même 1,5
kitty jeuland attend juste un petit
congé du bosphore mais mettez je
l'entends que les gens croient que les
gens des réseaux font pas grand chose
oui c'est vrai que notre vie est
relativement le faut noter c'est
relativement facile malgré tout nos boys
band ou est-ce que je vais m'en aller
qu'est ce que je fais avec ma plateforme
mais moi la danse en tant que vides j ai
réalisé qu est ce que je veux faire avec
ma plate forme le plus possible dit
c'est autant physique que ça peut
paraître c'est semer le bonheur mais non
ça c'est que je veux faire puis à
l'hôpital et je me rappelle qu'ankara
nice m'avait dit quand j'avais dit à
l'année je veux je veux pas faire
occupation double elle m'avait dit cap
en ce moment tout le monde à l'hôpital
un veau guérir le monde à grandeur du
québec
puis à partir de loches je suis resté
dans la même optique donc le jeu mélange
dans plein de projets mais juste pour
aider juste pour ce prêt de le bonheur
suprême puis ça va toujours rester mon
moto puis tant que tant que je vais
réussir à rendre une personne
heureux sont mes réseaux ou à l'hôpital
je veux me concentrer là dessus mais
l'eau les réseaux me prend énormément de
temps parce que j'ai un beau projet qui
qui va aider jean selon moi qu'il faut
ni qui me fait triper mais je l'on peut
pas encore parler naïve à la voudrait
savant delaveau c'est cette expression
vega mais bref mais c'est épuisant
travailler sur le dans mon temps parce
qu'elle en télétravail je fais vraiment
du 40 heures
je fais des appels je fais des hommes je
fais puis de l'autre bord je vais 20h à
30 heures à l'hôpital par ses mieux fait
de garder les deux mêmes médias qui est
la bonne cuisine le fait qu elle facture
je veux tellement garder les deux mains
monnier ça va me déchirer mais tant que
l'équilibré correct je peux continuer à
garder mon 20 40 ans parce que moi je
revenais à contrôler moi j'ai eu c'était
pas le talent donc j'ai pas été affecté
par le 40 heures semaine peut pas
imposer de commencer sa fac people
ben en fait non ils peuvent pas mais je
les prends twitter parce que je veux pas
que les infirmières en plus d'être
obligé de faire 40 ans font 48 ans moi
vu que j'en fais juste 20 ans je me
permets de faire 28 fait que souvent
quand il ya des ts aussi ça fait déjà
trois ou quatre que je fais depuis le
début de la pandémie
mais bref à suivre pour l' équilibre
mais dans le meilleur des mondes jusqu'à
vrai leader et les deux mais ça me
prendrait comme moins d'heures de
sommeil puis comme plus d'or dans une
semaine mais c'est le ballon et met
beaucoup mes t-shirts engagé jusqu'à la
fin du coc vide fait que je vais essayer
de garder l'équilibré si ça je sais
c'est détestable aussi mentalement de
toute fin j'imagine que la gratification
d'oeuvre est littéralement être
accompagné quelqu'un dans des temps
difficiles de maladie à l'hôpital doit
être la différence que tu fais tu la
vois instantanément 8 et peut-être plus
virtuellement il ya de faire palpiter
que oui les gens calmes en doute leur
retour mais c'est moins d'humain à
humain indirectement 00h07 dois
t'ennuyer mais c'est quand même pas tout
le monde que la chance que tout d'abord
sonné aussi creux tribunaux tandja qui
suit fact la différence que tu peux
faire
oui est intense pi et des humains mais
est grosso modique à travers les réseaux
triste individu seul absent c'est dur
c'est dur de vote et m oui mais donc je
prends mon exemple c'est précisément
laitiers mais donc moi d'aller dans un
refuge pays de prendre un chien qui a
été abandonné mais ton pour le sauver je
vais vous je vais avoir le contact
direct les combats de l'espace pour
seulement je comprends qu'on parle
maintenant de sauver la vie de ce chien
là va me demander énormément de temps et
d'énergie tié bi
je vais avoir la réaction directe avec
ce chien là je vais pouvoir voir le
résultat tient mais si par les réseaux
sociaux je réussi à convertir une
personne organismes et au minimum une
personne mais va sauver crissement plus
de vie d'animaux dans sa vie qu' une vie
de chien mais ton mais je la verrais pas
dans ma phase oui oui la c6 si je
convertis une personne aussi est juste
une personne qui change ses habitudes de
vie suite à mes publications
sauf que je le verrai potes je verrai
pas le chien qui me sourit fixé comme il
a encore une fois prenez braque la
comparaison la hors contexte sauf que
sauf que le principe est le même bac
puis comme je te dis moi je le vois pas
ces réseaux lisbourg savoir à qui j'en
reçois des messages de haine juste voir
distinguer aujourd'hui m'ont rendu
heureux juste suivre en comptant chaque
fois je vois une photo de toi c'était
chaque fois que je lis un texte chaque
fois que peace âge leur soit je le
reçois je le reçoive mais moi - les 285
mille personnes temps à moi qui me
suivent quotidiennement les 120 ml qui
voit mystery je les perçois poche je le
perçois vraiment poche parce que je
pense que c'est ce qui qui qui est beau
dans ce sens je les fais pour moi parce
que ça me fait du bien d'être sur les
réseaux peter moussa les ied
mais j'ai jamais vu ça comme une
régression robben jamais jamais jamais
jamais jamais même si ça reste dans ma
taille de vouloir aider mais à l'hôpital
par exemple quand j'amène juste
impatient aux toilettes qui a de la
misère à se lever
qu'ils aillent merci parce que moi je
carbure à seulement aidé pis le calme
c'est ça je me suis dit c'est la
première fois en trois ans que j'ai
vraiment l'impression de faire du bien à
quelqu'un juste parce que yi l'ofppt et
je peux le serrer dans mes bras
mais il ya eu juste pour ados si j'ai
des frissons aux vigies tellement de
peine que cette année ça puisse pas
avoir lieu mais juste pour ados les
adolescentes les jeunes les moins jeunes
qui crie ton nom puis qui 10h tellement
contente de rencontrer chaque jour je te
suis ça me fait triper mais moi je suis
comme briand dont que toutes ces
personnes ne me substitue les voiles
c'est des milliers des minutes personnes
devant toi qui font la file qui sont le
kick puis qu'il donne dans l'amont pi et
enfin de cette journée l'a jeté comme
acquis tant qu'une de ses dix mille
personnes vont me suivre encore je veux
continuer mais même là ça paraît je sais
pas j'ai encore mal à l'aise de dire
qu'elle gêne parce que je le perçois
pomès pour ça mon projet ça va tu dis
c'était la première fois en trois ans
que tu chantais vrai manque
que ted était concrètement est-ce que de
retourner à son occupation d'avant
l'occupation 2 est ce que est ce que ça
te met en perspective les dernières
années puis est ce que ça te ramener un
petit peu vers berck tt avant qu'est ce
que tu fais mais motivé avant ça oui
mais ça m'a plu sera mené les pieds sur
terre
t j'ai eu conscience de camp que ya des
gens des réseaux qui disent que c'est
difficile puisqu'ils ont travaillé fort
oui il y en a qui travaillent
extrêmement avant mes 40 heures semaine
à l'hôpital s'est trahi prêtres les
frais très fort débit c'est ça aussi
c'est différent la perspective est
différente donc ça m'a juste aidé à me
remettre les pieds sur terre puis ce que
j'aime c'est que depuis que je suis ici
depuis je retourne un fermier je
constate qu'un fermier et mon emploi il
ma profession piqué maintenant les
réseaux d'une passion c'est plus parce
que j'imagine que les deux ans après
rodez tél
c'était pas si tu t'étais non c'était un
plongeon oui oui j'étais encore
influence tendance à sous est ce que ça
c'est pas un terme qui me gêne et je
supposais france t'en sais pas si en
france tant que je ne sais pas j'avais
france bâbord mais c'est ça ça me
dérange pas parce que je dis j'espère
que chaque créateur de contenu pour
considère qu influence parce qu'ils font
des facs
soyez prudent avec tout qu'est ce que
vous publiez soyez moi c'est quand j'ai
vu justement toutes les petites filles
d'agis pour ado j'étais à qui tout elle
me suis donc vraiment je fasse attention
à qu'est-ce que je m'appuie faut tout
que j'y prenne comme s'il était mon
petit sac il faut je pense que de
retourner à l'hôpital m'ont ramené les
pieds sur terre m'a permis de jouer avec
mes réseaux sociaux mais mon encore fait
prendre conscience à quel point je suis
chanceux et chanceuses d'avoir tout ces
gens là qui m'écoutent métier très drôle
aussi de voir toutes les infirmières qui
me suivait ils connaissent tout le type
je vous il ya des préposés d'autres
étages son nouveau puits d un ferme et
puis aussi j'aimais sa 96e et 50 soit
parce que tu es on a quand même vraiment
ces foules de
2 le font pour rêve d'enfant qui en a
plein qui sont venus voir qu'ils aillent
moment for human rights
ça m'a fait penser à toi puisque j'ai
trouvé ce vraiment choquante a fait
depuis c'est devenu parler qu'ils me
suivent depuis depuis le tout début
depuis l'occupation de au petit je pense
que j'ai vraiment aussi beaucoup
d'infirmières derrière moi puis derrière
me réseau puis qui sont contentes de
voir où enfin à revient ouais puis des
fois connecté là dessus c'est un groupe
de monde que besoin de voix au city je
me rappelle si je partais en 2018 ou est
ce qu avait eu des critiques à
d'infirmières le dis ça pour faire
démissionner avec son numéro d'employés
il y avait eu une grande grande lettre
lui qui avait passé dans les réseaux
puis elle avait démissionné un pan
donnant son nom à donner son nom dans le
foyer parce que c'est un numéro
j'ai trouvé ça complètement exténué je
te mentir je me demande d'être mises à
part les locaux vides plus je peux
mettre dans une position politique
embarrassant ce qui m est tentée en 2018
je pense je pense que tant à paraître
qui étaient munies de la santé dans
stand up et c'était ce qui me semble que
c'était dit très très tendue entre les
professeurs la santé les infirmières pis
le gouvernement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
les conditions ont changé ce que si ce
que ça existe encore les bêtes sur le
site en touche par extension le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire est ce que ce
qui s'est encore aussi est ce que vous
sentez en vacances et puissant ce que tu
as encore aussi à bout de souffle ou ça
vaut mais un premier coûte je trouve ça
tellement petit parce que moi je me le
seul commentaire négatif que j'ai eu
quand je suis retournée à l'hôpital par
exemple ces puis j'en parlais dans un
show avec julie snyder puis je disais
que j'étais heureux je te contentes
j'étais à pia jobs ont pu y en a
quelques-unes qui ont dit ben oui mais
c'est normal ça fait trois ans dit paulo
mais avance trois ans se faisait cinq
ans que telle c'est moi j'ai commencé à
17 à 18 ans et un jour à l'hôpital
non mais vraiment noté j'avais out puis
j'avais fait mine
j'avais dix minutes si on me met mes
examens
cet ennemi petit j'avais aof - à 16 ans
je rentrais dans mon parcours dans des
familles qu'ils aiment ou des kits de
suite après mon bac fac c'était quoi la
question si les conditions je
travaillais cinq ans avant puis c'est
normal c'est sûr que moi j'essaie d'être
le plus positif mais je sais que des
fois envoyant seulement le bon côté
jeffrey l'autruche puis je mets mes yeux
je les fais dans ma vie moi je suis
maintenant mais si je dis je suis 100%
même je vois que le bon je le vois pas
ces négatifs mais je laisse passer pour
moi qui me dérange pour pas l'avoir
entendu - oui chiant comme tout le monde
je peux shirli parce que ça fait du bien
de sortir mais puisque je parle pas du
mouvement ce moment mais moi je
considère que mes temps qu'est ce que tu
peux pas changer s'il accepte il tente
mais le et je pense posture pour le
mouvement pas mal mais je parle plus des
conditions à l'hôpital mais moi je pense
de même puisqu'ils fait que serait une
très mauvaise leader dans le mouvement
de changement métier je veux pas on en
avait parlé à l'hôpital c'est le lion
géant jamais autant eu besoin de nous
faire pourquoi est ce que l'on se
révoltent pas vite et ça a été une
pensée petit après on y retourne adjobi
je veux dirigeants ont tout le corps
puis nous on décide d'être engrais opté
en même temps on est toutes des gens
tellement le truisme que comment tu veux
des gens instruits se disent mon
passe-temps l'hôpital va sécher pour que
de l'autre bord
ils soutiennent notre jeu pourrait pas
être atteint dit j'espère comme emmener
quelqu'un de vraiment si je veux c'est
sûr qu'il ya des conditions météo
si je veux daily li l'augmentation le
suspect qui avait pas de vacances à ceux
qui arrivent à campsas plus que six à
tous que ce que je comprends que celle
les obligations radio covin mais il ya
quand même temps on aurait pu profiter
de tout pour faire un changement puis on
est tout aussi te dis moi c'est comme se
dit je pense que le celi vie ali vie
humaine avant tout
exactement peut-être peut-être après
castres le temps de faire le post mortem
de tout ce tir qui et comment qu'on a
géré la crise puis qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire mieux qu'elle soit pas améliorée
le sait peut-être le temps des tapis
éventuellement j'aimerais ça parce que
je connais mon influence puis j'aimerais
se voir qu'est-ce que je peux faire par
rapport à ça puis j'y pense souvent mais
en ce moment une solution instantanée
magique qui en a pas on sait par des
petits pas des petites victoires et je
veux des noirs l'hôpital avec notre chef
on a déjà négocié des trucs on est
content parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on
a eu juste il faut que je pense que
c'est de s'asseoir de discuter ça peut
pas se faire en une journée mais c'est
vrai qu'il faudrait qu est ce que ça te
fait demander par mettons les gens
autour de toi de ta profession de
devenir une lourde porte parole pour non
non non
[Rires]
les régents bien aux roses entrée de
gamme tout va bien parce qu'ici même pas
que je me vois mais j'ai tenté j'ai dit
mme avant la passe mais c'est que je le
vois pas comme que dans une relation
d'amitié je vois pas le négatif puis des
fois c'est des fois ça peut être joué
que moi je suis pas naïve je décide de
voir de l'autre côté puis c'est dans ma
vie jusqu'à présent ça va super bien
fonctionné fans enfin je connais que je
continue comme ça mais c'est ça c'est
ici non moi ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est vraiment le mouvement des concours
avec quinze jours puis de faire des
vidéos pour semer vraiment pour ça mais
quelque chose de positif sur les réseaux
donc c'est nous on avait fait une danse
tictoc avec ma gagne mais c'est parce
qu'après les trois heures après cette
danse leur oui on soigner nos patients
mais au lieu de chialer sur le fait que
c'était lourd on criait dans des
garanties si je le dis dans une pause on
a eu tellement ri là dessus pendant
trois heures le sien on aurait voulu en
faire tout un pays je pense que c'est
c'est pour ça que les infirmiers on en
fait autant aussi c'est parce que ça
décompressait comme une personne n'a
écrit aykaç recettes manioc fita danse
finalement le fait depuis et on ne rit
ces malades
ces deux équipes étaient égaux est folle
pays avec ce on a donné je pense que 680
livre de bonbons à 15 départements
différents 680 lui avec angie oui oui
donc on a donné sa pitié on a même fait
embarquer les ambulanciers les pompili
police ça on a fait un gros mouvement il
y avait plein temps ce qui passé puisque
je trouve que c'est une façon de montrer
le positif mais en même temps de montrer
car dès les informant son adjobi travail
même si dans cette vidéo le voile juste
une danse méthon mais pour ça en
échanges restent à la maison
mettez aussi si tu me demander si je
veux être le changement pas vraiment
mais dans ça je veux pas être la tête de
ce mois je soutiendrai quelques intimes
mais il ya plein de petits trucs
tellement le fun ces jeux d'essai dans
sa soit ce que essayé d'emmener une
influence positivement à l'hôpital mais
ça c'est juste à mon hôpital pour les
autres mexicaine jour on essaie de faire
avec un petit déclic au sénat mais
partout de la gaspésie saguenay qui
faisait vivre avec ça et j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment choc mais sinon il ya plein de
compagnies noté météo gourou qui m'ont
envoyé plein plein 15 pour les
infirmières et arédia qui me donnait 100
sans une forme je le porte le mess à une
forme pour aller avant la job parce
qu'il sait qu on change souvent
s'il ya tellement de compagnie qui m'ont
dit icat on veut c il faut que ce j'ai
trouvé ça cool parce que je j'ai comme
réussi à emmener en france hors de moi
tout les gratuités je reçois toutes les
ligues dispositif tout petit on sent une
tablette était la première tant ce qu'on
a reçue je sais pas si tu perds ce temps
mais je suis détendu détention d'armes
et et apprenez à rabat et or ce système
en comptes à leurs soins
mettez moi j'ai essayé de faire ça à
grandeur de monde parle parce que je
peux pas le faire partout mais juste
c'était essayer de mettre les deux c'est
plus dans cette direction le que
j'essaierai de dijonnais mal moi j'ai
trouvé ça beau qui est tellement de
compagnie pour pas pour une fois mais
veulent teegarden qui a donné 300 paires
de souliers hier mon hôpital des
factures j'ai trouvé ça l'fun de voir
que les compagnies voulait aider parce
que je me dirige
ce sont le vus on le vit beaucoup leur
espèce de ralliement derrière les
professionnels de la santé nous mêmes on
a donné des plats au chum au profit de
la santé du chien alors si simple lot
puis petit on l'a vu bien maintenant
c'est d'espérer que cette espèce de
désir de coin de partager puis de
données demeurent têtus sais c'est
difficile de voir en ce moment sur tout
et qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
fait
100% de façon altruiste ou qu'est ce qui
est fait pour une question de brenda oui
ça c'est vraiment difficile de
différencier puis on va le voir quand
qu'on va sortir de cette crise là parce
qu'en ce moment
puis on le voit c'est dans toutes ses
mains même en ce moment avec ce qui se
passe aux états unis dit il ya tout le
temps une question de si trendy on a
embarqué là-dedans c'est fait que c'est
de voir comment qu'on fait pour que ça
dure que ça durait oui gardé cette idée
la sks qui aussitôt que la cabine s'est
réglé puisque ce qu'est ce qui est ce
que les profils de sentir tombe à l'eau
qui vont être épuisé ben oui on fait 1 1
à 40 heures semaine c'est à petit parce
que dis je le peux et vermeer fois en 40
ans parce que c'est brûlant je dirais
qu'on fait pas mal tout plus de 24 32
fac après avons quarante ans après à vos
postes vacants ce mec locaux vides soit
amené à ce qu'ils vont dire à bettié
vous retourner comme nous étions rivaux
moi je pense que c'est quelque chose
comme ça qui va arriver mais ce serait
vraiment désolant de chabrot dit vous
êtes le héros vous êtes les héros vous
êtes les roues vous êtes oublier au
revoir merci pour tout ce que vous avez
fait fautif à ce que j'aimerais c'est
que ça perdure pour autant pour les
compagnies que pour ces jeux en tout cas
ils vont vraiment été plus apprécié et
puis j'espère que ça va perdurer
c'est fou c'est vraiment en ce moment en
ce moment j'imagine autant pour le
gouvernement pour les entreprises pour
les individus c'est vraiment là où tout
le monde parle tout le monde parle
attendons de voir des actions puis
espérons en voir autant le gouvernement
qui parle pour les laisser chez celles
des as a pas de bon sens a provoqué
quand ça va être fini le qu'est ce qui
va compter c'est la même chose pour est
ce que est ce que la coved et finit plus
au québec on va on va monter le salaire
des médecins spécialistes puis on va
laisser les infirmières aux salaires qui
sont actuellement puis avec les
conditions qui ont été ses comptes va se
passer hier devant juste matin je les ai
passées chez celles déposées militiaires
le trio notent ils vont avoir des
meilleures conditions il avait remercié
là ils veulent en forme et wigan de juin
à septembre trois mois ils vont en payer
pour leur formation c'est magique lotis
dans sa vente était pas payer pour
étudier pour être prêt pour nous tu vas
avoir trois mois payés donc tout les
jours c'est beau et chaud seule femme
puis tu es moi j'avais vu legault dire
que c'était une jeune gratifiant j'avais
entendu quelqu'un à côté des maillots
jaunes gratifiante implanté cité puis
jeté comme un accident très gratifiant
petit tu veux voir une personne malade
que céline cloche parce qu a besoin de
quelque chose que ce soit un médicament
pour le droit d'aller aux toilettes de
se lever et de s'asseoir une boîte de
kleenex que tu veuilles parti pis est
tellement reconnaissante d'avoir reçu
une boîte de kleenex que moi je trouve
que c'est une job c'est que pour l'avoir
fait deux ans ne parle pas très bien mon
chapeau moi je lis souvent dit des fois
j'aimerais presque se retourne et
préposés moi j'aimais ça répond donc là
je veux des actes graves pour ceux qui
veulent l'essayer
ben quoi de mieux que d'être payés il
faut juste que là il faut juste que le
salaire des fois suivre la gratification
mois qu'ils ont eu tendance à augmenter
voire de meilleures conditions puisque
je faisais bague
par contre c'est que le cédant les ch
tis elle dit donc ski gouvernementales
mais qui dans l'eee mettons les les
maisons privées le tri finalement jazz
de ce monde bâti ouais c'est sûr le tout
les établissements privés belle aux
autres il ya encore des préposés
publisac travail à 14h30 et à sa voiture
vide est ce parce qu'ils vont s'en aller
travailler tpiy fait le job dû
transposer problème ailleurs fait le
sait ce qu'ils foutent shakeel mais je
pense que parce que c'est quand même
dans sa main
mais jamais pour en revenir à ce que tu
disais tu espères que ça va continuer de
se mettre au moins un travail mais
réseau je sais pas je les dis combien de
fois mais si vous connaissez quelqu'un
de la santé puis moi je parle beaucoup
des infirmières mais on parle on a parlé
des préposés mais je parle aussi dit
dans l'eau dit qu'une micro de légers
dégâts de nommer je tiens à le dire
parce que justement je me le fais
souvent des dix pas juste des
infirmières mais qui mènent tous ceux
qui ont travaillé à travers la crise
directement avec le public
chapeau le job done c'est incroyable qui
justement moi j'arrête pas de dire la
maison si vous connaissez un infirmières
préposés personnel comment t'appelles ça
l'entretien ménager
j'ai dit à y créer un james était
vraiment en bon augure pour ce que tu
fais parce que recevoir ceux aux revenus
r je suis de votre avis petit comme ces
filles ont besoin de sauter l'eau c'est
beau il lit les gens de la santé étaient
des héros mais je veux pas justement sa
drogue à long terme même si c'est juste
mon entourage que ton entourage t'arrête
pas arrête pas de moi je veux dire mon
père était tellement fier que j'étais
infirmière moto mais cherche un ferme en
disputant juste à cause de ce juste eu
fière d'être infirmière je suis fier d
qu'est ce que je fais quelque chose que
justement si les compagnies s'étaient
manqués ténoise wii développé qui
continue pas ben nous on peut continuer
si vous pouviez et good job si j'espère
que tous ceux qui m'écoutent en ce
moment vont qui nous écoutent vont aller
créer à quelqu'un qui connaît pas ce
qu'on connaît tous quelqu'un de la santé
puis dire allez salut good jobs serait
jamais ce que tu fais mais tu es tu
vraiment chapeau aux gentils qui ont
répondu à l'appel aussi de dalé est
délimitée comme acquis mais si je devais
moi j'écoutais les écouter les
conférences de presse quand le goût des
genres allez-y en charge monde allait
prêter main-forte seppi j'ai eu un petit
minot dave pourquoi pas moi je pourrais
y aller l'argent pis sauf que je parlais
succès mais ceux qui sont là bas j'ai
dit mon temps palais
est ce qu'ils sont actually aller japon
absolument ce qui est des héros demain
comme des héros qui étaient retraités
ça veut dire qu'ils sont arrêtés donc
son propre 60 ans et plus dont sont à
l'isesco vide qui sont venus ce j'en ai
vu le des retraités se serait simplement
maladie job done nantis peut rester chez
vous il retourne ainsi nantis jeudi et
nous y avait une femme en solidité qui
pendant deux mois sont comme ces enfants
vu au chalet elle avait tellement peur
de leurs données kelly l'a pas vue
pendant deux mois il faisait 40 48 56
heures à john banc tandis que vides pour
aider pour dépanner puis une chance
qu'on en a qui font qu'ils aiment et
qu'ils font et qui veulent faire plus de
temps supplémentaire parce que sinon ça
se transformerait vraiment intéressant
factice et plein de heroes qui se sont
manifestés mais que qui ont vraiment
fait une science
tantôt tu parlais des de prendre le
temps de reconnaître le travail de
quelqu'un dirait de job dit comment tu
te dis c'est une pépite et j'écoutais
françois lambert qui parlait
d'entrepreneuriat pitch était employé il
ya trois affaires qui ont employé vous
il dit la première chose qu'ils plus
importantes que le salaire c'est la
gratification puis 6-5 gratifié d'être
de travailler ça vaut plus qu'un salaire
puis puis honnêtement de te faire dire
est ce que tu fais c'est bon si c'est
bon ce que tu fais c'est bien ce que tu
fais c'est courageux ben c'est vrai que
ça la connaît
j'espère tellement que plein de bosses
tu écoutes en ce moment parce que c'est
facile c'est quoi
good job cette semaine à wau chapeau
vous avez vraiment géré la situation
juste d'être au courant parce qu'ils
sont paul holmes et ont par exemple nous
on est deux soirs dans cet emploi donc
ils savent pas mais on entend de part
les factures au lieu de nous rencontrer
sur toutes nos mauvais mouvement c'est
le fun piste est facile d mais ils font
moi mais j'espère que y apprenait une
bosse qui t'écoutent puis qui vont se
mettre à le faire plus parce que c'est
vrai
c'est vrai autant des patrons que de
l'entourage mais la gratification je
pense qu'elle vient aussi avec le
sentiment que toutes les ressources à
des instructions pour pouvoir bien faire
ton travail
et puis je te manquer qu'on entend les
cris du coeur des préposés aux
bénéficiaires ou des infirmières souvent
c'est les larmes c'est à cause que ils
ont trop de patients sont débordés sont
ils sont capables de bien faire leur job
c'est celle qui est restée voudrait des
on voudrait sauver civile et on voudrait
que les gens à une unité les gens les
bonnes conditions on peut pas leur
donner parce que j ai 50 ans
ah ouais mais moi je l'aï toujours dit
le sim est en jeu gagnée aux millions
qu'il est géré à l'hôpital petits rémois
je veux deux patients moi je veux des
patients maximum et 4 parce que des fois
on peut y avoir jusqu'à 8 puis 10 dans
mon unité dans ch et celle du cbb mais
mettons - gera l'eau potable j'irai j'en
veux 2,4 maximum puis je te les
chouchous moi je vais te un moment même
pas de préposés mais ce c'est une femme
qui saute à raison c'est gratifiant
parce que là je ferai tout je parlerai à
la famille je les emmènerai aux
toilettes je verrai leur mobilité je
verrai ça c'est le jam de toutes les
infirmières aussi je veux d'abord
vraiment juste quatre patients sa charge
puis pas d instable si j'ai des
instables j'en veux dit mange en veut
moins mais seuls moi je me suis toujours
dit c'est ce que je pense c'est surgelés
frais pis je pense c'est vrai parce que
le show venu puis j'avais pas
nécessairement à mes factures 100%
raison qui pendant le pire de la crise
le haut débit est au début tu avais tu
l'impression de complètement noyée sous
tout le travail puisse pas être capable
de bien faire ton travail ou août ça se
fait c'est intégré et non c'était bien
parce que est survenu le puis j'ai
l'impression jamais parti il devait
vraiment que me demander des conseils
métier j'avais quand même été longtemps
à l'hôpital dont au moins pour sopi
d'étudier la gratitude mais aussi le
feeling d'être bon dans ce que tu fais
tu es moins 6 pour un texte aussi infâme
ans j'ai vraiment l'impression que tg
les connaissances je suis bon outil
scheid j'adore ça je suis rapide et puis
si ça peut être que dans une france en
jeu mais je sais que je trouve toujours
jean maladroite ou à l'est mais c 'est
ce débat nous
marché kodak mais je pense que justement
c'est mon innocence kitty jusqu'au bout
des bugs mais encore une fois être
l'impression que tu habites les
ressources pour bien faire notre travail
by encore le jeu sinon mais j'arrive pas
dire n'importe quoi
et oui parce qu'on a quand même
plusieurs appels à faire par exemple si
j'ai pas le temps de faire une prise et
ça je peux appeler une informant qu'ils
se promènent dans l'hôpital si j'ai une
question de cliniques je peux appeler
une infirmière qui travaille dans le but
a donc pour les ressources
oui - - c'était beaucoup plus et ils
comment je peux réussir à continuer ses
réseaux parce que le tout le monde ses
réseaux les influenceurs en fait ce
qu'ils devaient faire puis s'étaient
montrés positifs pu montrer leurs
projets puis divertir les gentils moi je
trouvais ça malades les lifes les lives
instagram ou peu importe quoi les
podcasts parce que les gens devaient
être diverti à maison blanche tu es
comme mais moi j'avais pas vous tire du
positif
j'ai beaucoup donné à la gagne ça va
bien aller je t'ai déjà papa bastareaud
belge au boubou de stefan joho comme
étant une maîtrise ont fait pendant les
temps deux semaines et qui était
discrète mais là je fais une anxiété
parce que je veux être présent puis je
veux le dire des trucs qui ont posé des
questions mais là je marche sur des
oeufs factices moi c'est beaucoup plus
les maîtres des deux de devoir être
positive sans nécessairement penser que
ça allait bien mais ça serait vraiment
le mont gros dans ce début mai trois
premiers jours puis après ça justement
je me souviens c'est et puis je suis
parti pis le nom j'ai vraiment
l'impression que quand y'a de quoi
j'appelle pin ou par exemple on a une
infirmière clinique pour aider toutes
les infirmières en bas de cinq ans dans
toutes leurs questions pire là il
finalement tout le monde mais elle c'est
une encyclopédie sur pattes puis elle a
ce problème d'une tendinite et yann
félicite quand nous emmène d ibm
qualification mais en même temps de
répondre à toutes nos questions là j'ai
une question sur la fin la plus picchi
pointe youtube à l'entrée pas en fac
elle c'est une ressource incroyable
j'espère que chaque hôpital en europe je
pense que moi où est ce que je suis pour
ça on est vraiment bien encadré est ce
que on a eu au québec un moment où est
ce que les hôpitaux ont été submergés
ont été remplis au complet au québec ce
mémorial parlons de montréal plus que
ouais mais même mais maintenant je pense
parce que maintenant c'était cela
c'était c'est la plus grande inquiétude
quand ça a commencé l'inquiétude c'était
on n'a pas assez de tout on n'a pas
assez de staff on a passé le matériel on
n'a pas assez de ventilateurs ne pas
aimer aussi par exemple les soins
intensifs étaient engorgés laisse
finalement qu'ils allaient papillon
faisait quoi vic exact c'est mais est-ce
qu'on attend ce je peux pas parler pour
partout hein mais je ne crois pas parce
que je pense qu'on aurait été beaucoup
plus au courant mais nous on a toujours
réussi à équilibrer le factice
parce que c'est grave c'était comme seul
l'objectif numéro un du confinement
s'est-elle d'aplatir la fameuse courbe
pour éviter pour éviter le making of
windsor l'eau mais oui mais s'imagine
dessus aux soins intensifs
il reste une plogue sais c'est que
mettons pas ce qu'est ce que tu vas en
horreur le voyez ça fait là mais moi de
mon côté j'en ai eu 2 35 1 qui se porte
qui se portaient super by ks faire bien
avec 7 qui a besoin aient lieu mais j'en
une onde de 70 et jeu mais qui sait ce
exact aussi je sais ce qui s'est passé
s'est exposée à l'italie ce qui était
incarcéré images qu'on avait l'est du
mont houy hamonistes et puante 50 entre
56 et prenait même puce 50 ans et toutes
nos paroles mais je n'ai jamais ressenti
fait somme toute somme toute mais tant
que l'on est à la base la première
courbe somme toute la planète mans de la
courbe gay n'était que je pense que les
passions je pense ça dépend vraiment
justement comme disait d'un
établissement à l'autre le témoin
j'avais entendu je partais
sacré coeur qui disait qu on est
complètement submergé on n'est pas
capable d'arriver très fier de ce qu'il
a entendu aussi que c'est qu'il ya
certains hôpitaux qui voulait pas de wi
fi ns autres d'automne il pas exclu on
veut pas dire que ça comment transférer
qui transfèrent ailleurs calculé ça fait
que certaines places qu'ici fulco vide
le danger ripper des places qui vous le
restez toujours mais c'est cool je sais
pas mais je me dis est ce que ces gens
là avaient des soins avancés trop peu
développée est ce que t il peut avoir
une raison le moi pourquoi justement
différence face de transférer dans un
hôpital puis on se demandait tout
pourquoi que ils prenaient pas mais
c'est sûr que ça le tout était réfléchi
puis ils voulaient des dix unités 5
peut-être que il y avait beaucoup plus
de d'hématologie pi2 système immunitaire
affaibli donc ils en voulaient pas du
tout est ce que tout les gens plus
faibles il est envoyé là bas mais en
somme je pense que commun qui ont
réparti sur c'était bien épicée pas sait
pas on ne veut pas les prendre
saleh était franchement bien décider cet
hôpital le iwwert pour telle ou telle
raison
satisfait pas vraiment quelque chose qui
me dérange c'est quand qu'ils ont voulu
transferts on peut pas la bonne mais
c'est une bonne nouvelle somme toute il
faut il faut ce qu'il faut est capable
c'est autant moins que jude était
mentalement d'aidé hop des bottes durant
les deux mois et demi qu'on vient de
passer l'été comme tu entends quelque
chose là qui te fait paniquer tentant
quelque chose d'autre bord c'est comment
faire mentir ça va plus après ça c'est
comme ça savary ça fluctue comme ce
puits puis d'arriver au temps on disait
que possiblement qui voit une deuxième
vague qui vous qui qui qui crée une
certaine anxiété autant là on peut se
dire la gestion de la crise sont tout
était correct mais moi je pense qu'on
veut vraiment je pense qu'on va avoir
les listes hâte qu'on va voir vraiment
une bonne aperçu le slam en cause depuis
si vraiment utilisé une fois connu le
virus bâtisse à s'accoupler un soutien
mesuré d'information là-dessus
dernièrement c'est au neuf
c'est vrai on ne sait pas hier j'ai
parlé à mon père qui est quand même
assez informés sur ce sujet le lit puis
il disait on n'a pas de preuves
tangibles que tu peux pas être
réinfectées après il rien qui prouve que
faudrait tellement que les quelqu'un
qu'il a eu deux fois mais c'était la
force et qui disent qu'en ce moment sont
en train de penser qu'il ya du monde
un peu partout dans le monde qu'ils ont
deux fois puis il voit d'aidé comme ils
sont pas de confirmer si ils insistent
elles une deuxième fois au système qui
est encore dormant donc si on fait que
c'est comme seul le problème sauf qu'il
n'ya rien qui confirme que tu peux pas
l'avoir deux fois une fois que le virus
a muté mais c'est cette exigence effet
qu on le sait pas si tous les
questionnements par rapport à sa
publication pour répondre lui-même au
début quand on parlait les façons de les
traiter lui ça va être les vaccins
actions pour en parler longtemps duval
aussi ce fake c'est vraiment encore un
mr puis on espère que justement ça va
tout à lire dans la meilleure direction
mais c'était dessus irrité par par tout
livre mauvaise information
9 heures
moi pour être 100 % en un an j'étais
tellement dedans puis je crois tu es moi
j'ai mes croyances comme que chaque est
fermé à ces croyances comme que chaque
personne qui comme les gens qui on la
croit en ce qu'il n'existe pas et j'en
ai parlé la décennie quittez vos caves
et expo puis pas juste des amis ou à moi
je l'aï jamais été skywater s'est
inventé pitt et cotes d écoute moi j'en
ai entassés à five on nous donne et les
vaccins ils vont nous implanter des
pulsions d'andré telman d'affamés mois
un certain point j mee croyance à
l'hôpital je vois directement je crois
qu est ce que je vois donc les
informations comme que c'est le coach
qui dit j'ai élu une fois j'ai même
politique chez qui la source si je le
dis dans ce sens qui en a tellement eu
tu vois les effets que jacques foccart
de l'algérie devant toi le sait ça c'est
sa vie mais j'ai des preuves tangibles
que je vois le résultat quelque chose
fonctionne la joie y croient en moi je
lit plein d'informations par ci par le
jeu les écoles je les entends est-ce que
je les crois pas nécessairement des fois
dans une conversation je lui dis mais
moins je parle beaucoup plus en fonction
de qu'est ce que j'ai vu le donc moi ces
informations la mairie de pau mais c'est
ce au moins les regarder la source des
informations qui me lisez ce que je sais
même pas si je vais déjà voir les
voisins de gommer ces défauts état
physique pour darty qui sont partagés de
toute l'ue mais nous on a vraiment des
bonnes formations sur la transmission ou
comment se protéger comme un délice
symptômes on est une lily symptômes très
claire de ce qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que tu présentes nous sommes
en présente deux faut automatiquement
les se faire dépister chose que j jarret
fait-il par exemple il ya mal de tête
fatigue mais j'suis pas les jambes
mais c'est ça donc nous c'est vraiment
bien fait comment quelqu'un qu'on a des
symptômes ou pas aussi j'ai soupé avec
une fille qui a été positif que jamais
faire tester donc ça et ça m'a permis
d'avoir mis propres croyances de à l
allure est là le point pourquoi est ce
que en fonction
est-ce que vous avez des formations
continues imagine que oui il va faire le
salut cela le web et même qu'elle a
justement vu qu'on est un symptôme grave
il ya des formations qu'on pense qu'on
aurait dû avoir mais que pourrait être
cette d'une telle oeuvre nous on était
néphrologie nom n'était pas du tout soin
mais ils nous ont envoyés des
infirmières de cardiologie qui eux nous
haye depuis londres des formations qu'on
n'avait jamais eu comme les rv au dub
hip hop la télémétrie qu'il faut
absolument avoir mais aussitôt que
l'information soit qui ça se peut que
les patients qui avaient d'ailleurs be
bop dame est ce que vous avez une
nouvelle fois way aux 35 heures
obligatoires pis pour la connaissance
est repassé à surmonter
je reposte récit je pense que je peux
déjà sauté pour pousser métrage au pyla
et coûteront soignant son image de tout
toutes les informations de leur lit
formation en et des listes de formation
qu'on dit moi je veux le moindre but le
mont joux l'a donc franchement là pour
la continuité des soins pis les
formations ça c'est qu'il couche c'est
vraiment toi c'est réconfortant
ouais ouais on attend du positivisme
c'est quelqu'un qui compte dans ce petit
monde à on attend tellement je
fonctionne pas ouais ouais mais c'est ça
mais non pour pour cet aspect l'homme
moi je trouve ça vraiment vraiment très
très bien que très très simple j'ai eu
beaucoup de formation des pêcheurs venus
même si jusque là contre eux même si sa
poisse tu vas être informés après même
si sion vraiment trouvais ça important
de même me former mois pour tout ces
petits détails le qui aurait pu dire ktm
pas temps plein est exactement
exactement mais au final non moi aussi
je fais parti d'halifax et 6 pour la
santé des patients le saumon
je peux parler de mon expérience mon
unité c'est génial qui loge jeu je
voudrais revenir sur quelque chose qui
était dit tantôt de commence alors mis
en perspective
qu'est-ce que du travail quand est
revenue comme infirmière de dire 40
heures par semaine de télétravail chez
vous achetez à gérer du contenu pour
préparer des projets j'imagine
comparativement à 40 heures sur le
plancher à travailler ça remet quand
même en perspective
certaines idées qui sont transmises sur
les réseaux sociaux
oui puis on entend souvent l'espèce de
un travail vraiment fait sur mon projet
souvent même on l'entend en excuses 2 à
2 j'ai tellement travaillé fort sur
saône ans et sa pilule moi je parle d'un
projet s'est créé l'impasse mais c'est
parce que c'est la première fois que
j'en ai réellement un j'en ai jamais dit
ce sont mes réseaux j'en ai jamais parlé
sur mes réseaux - histoire du projet
secret qui s'en vient
et puis je dis je lis fait l'homme est
ce parce que c'était un lien avec tout
ce que ça me vaut mais je le dis pas
dans mystery pige pas et je mets ce que
j'étais absente à constater à quel point
c'est ce genre comme une lame ça depuis
que j'ai maté j'ai toujours eu un petit
peu de difficulté à on travaille fort
c'est vrai qu'on travaille fort mais on
pourrait tellement travaillé encore si
je dis même moins l'oeil écoute cheikh
garantie que le - daf on accroche que
sam a admis si je travaillais pas fort
ouais j'aurais pas fort ce port et c'est
dans ce sens
non mais c'est vrai qu'une affaire bien
plus fort
non mais t'es c'est donc dès que je suis
pour rien mais parce que aussi jusqu'à
ce que je trouve c'est que y'a renom qui
ont jamais eu une réelle jobs se
surveillent j'aimerais ceux qui appuient
une réelle job mais ce qu'il devra est
enfin essentielle de ce qui se serait
passé si je le pense mais d'enfance n'y
a jamais eu un 40 ans semaine avec un
patron qui est un bon petit chèque c'est
ça avec et des qualifications
spécifiques c'est magnifique halle
le travail des français parce que
justement devient ton propre boss mais
moins avant j'avais un boss puis quand
je suis devenu mon provoost a peut-être
une bonne c'est le début d'un sens où
est ce que je disais j'ai pas que je
travaillais fort parce que j'avais moi
moi je considérais et 40 heures semaine
dit peut-être quand on a moins de bruit
dans parce que en tant qu'un français
quand il cherche moi je trouve que
l'hybride down sont au 9 mai
physiquement mentalement 1 40 heures
semaine à l'hôpital
c'est extrêmement l'eau puis moi la
coche que ça mal mais c'est heizmann
depuis deux ans j'avais mis 40 60 ans
dans la journée un job étudiant c'est un
métier c'est aussi quelque chose ici sa
web série podcasts vidéos photos ou 1
370 ch je faisais je faisais vraiment
plein d'affaires mais tout décousu puis
la régularité de mon rôle des femmes en
parce que j'ai pas le choix parce qu'à
16 heures je dois être léopard 4,7 en 30
jours avant tout une mise à faire pour
manger parce qu'à 20 ans je veux
recommencer ma tournée parce que sosa
mots tellement motivé am the heights
faisait rien une typo rien mais fac j'ai
doublé ce que je faisais en france mais
on recommence à l'hôpital mais j'ai
l'impression que l'hôpital m'ont aidé
parce que maintenant chez je travaille
et je lui dis on aurait dit ça mange pas
je sais que j'ai les lundi mardi
mercredi seulement donc maintenant quand
je m'active support pour ouvrir mais
pour moi c'était difficile des réseaux
c'est une journée ça me tentait pas au
pij avait rien à remettre piste est pour
dans deux semaines ouais et j'attendais
d'eux mêmes j'exagère mais il ya un
déclic moi qui s'est fait justement
parce que j'avais l'impression jeter
comme crise que je travaille fort on
reste ici il n'y a pas grand-chose qui
avance t dans mes projets ou de waverly
puis se situe au début le peut-être
l'année après une sortie d'audi le oui
j'étais quand même
qu'est ce que je fais finalement puis
il y avait le concept de merde prendre
toutes les heures active que tu fais ce
que tu fais réellement quelque chose
prend un calendrier d'une semaine un
agenda commun aux primaires rentrer
toutes ces or le bac à bac dans ta
semaine qui regarde combien d'heures tu
files mais c'est quand même je fais 10
heures 14 heures c'est ce genre c'est
sûr ça avance
mon dieu quelle quel patron fréquemment
sérieusement mais c'est sale c'est assez
pour cette semaine maintenant voici ton
cher et ça ouais non mais c'est ça mais
moi maintenant si j'ai appris à bien
m'en sers tiges et après avoir des
meetings même pas nécessaire mais juste
pour brainstorm avec 26 on est souvent
tout seul inscrit son aura ta colloque
tes parents y travaillent sont politique
c'est la maison de personnes qui te
regardes tu commences à faire deux
enfants puis oui tu as l'impression de
faire de quoi puis même que des photos
des bugs donne parce que tu es comme
amusant je fais plein de rafah justement
comme te dis ça avance pas mais après ça
tu regardes ça puis comme je veux tu te
mets ça de réaliser ça je trouve que
c'est c'la plus c'est la plus belle en
face à moi pilotes il ya en un qui font
énormément de trucs qui sont proactifs
qui sont bons pour travailler tout seul
mais de voir ce qu'on l'entende si on
l'entend beaucoup les jeux travaille
tellement fort sur x ou y dit je suppose
que oui je pense si le réalisme
ben c'est son nom mais ça c'est la
perception ceux qui travaillent fort
mais ce que ce travail le dit justement
toi le fait de retourner travailler à
l'hôpital sa structure je te mentir en
tête alors été tranchée ce topo tous eu
à réfléchir en plus tu sais la
difficulté des travailleurs autonomes
ces soucis d'être capable d'avoir ces
structures le sens qu'il soit imposé de
cépie ce qu'est ce qu'elle est belle et
influença ou prépa travailleurs
autonomes qui travaillent 70
sauf que city studios productive ce que
tu pourrais mieux rentabiliser ton temps
tu te à l'hôpital tout organisé pour que
le temps soit le plus efficace possible
j'imagine pour tous
ouais même visage en y réfléchissant
c'est que moi jour en france c'est
frustrant parce que tu as plein d'idées
mais pas nécessairement n'est pas
qualifié en battant moi je voulais faire
une vidéo youtube manger varié le jeu
mais patente être quoi c'était pourri le
son était pas bon je vais pas mettre ça
recommence tu abandonnes t comment qui
jouera au jour j pour les qualifications
mais j'ai appris à bien entouré
maintenant j'ai envie d agen montargis
hippie jégou de montrer des affaires
vraiment le fun que j'y réfléchis pas
juste faire une vidéo parce que ça
faisait longtemps que j'en avais pas
j'en avais pas fait une fac tu es je
pense que c'est
c'est tout ça c'est que c'est frustrant
hausse c'est frustrant pour tout seul
c'est frustrant c'est de ne pas avoir
une cause
c'est même moi encore aujourd'hui je ris
parce que tu es il ya avant hier j'ai
croisé quelqu'un dans le milieu qui est
maudit j'adore ce que tu fais en parler
des réseaux par semaine s'est couché
puis mais c'est moi ou un certain point
j'ai accepté qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
que je ne voulais pas faire juste pour
dire que je faisais de quoi piquer j pas
nécessairement une cause
tj pas une cause j'ai plein de valeurs
pis je monte mes valeurs puis-je mon
quotidien et puis je montre tout le
temps ma façon de penser
face à mon quotidien ce qui moi m'a aidé
parce que j'ai appris dans des livres et
man down comme en commun que
automatiquement je me relève mais ça
j'essaie de la prendre puis de le
propager puis au pire
ma cause si je veux que ce soit ce sera
juste si je trouve que y'en a qui se
cherche des causes puis que ça paraît
mais crypte au toit phare soit juste toi
parce que si ton autant un groupe alloin
c'est que les gens sont émus pour qui tu
étais petit secteur subit le de levier
ma frustration d'entendre vraiment
souvent de la vieille école temps avant
le nous le on idéalise à des gens qui
avaient des vrais talents honda lisais
des gens qui jouent au soccer qui était
bon beckham parce que j avais le talent
on idéalise et des comédiens ont ni
d'alizay des acteurs mais quoi mais quoi
de plus beau que dia d'idéaliser une
personnalité s'étant beckham ne
peut-être que tous les soirs je veux tu
sais pas qu'est ce qu'il faisait
peut-être qu'ici je le dis combien une
fois qu'on entend des grands
n'en sont que en particulier
possiblement que je sais faire une idée
une vengeance ou est ce que moi je
recherche ce qu'une fille me suit puis
de recevoir des messages de maman de ma
fille tu suis qui à cause de toi et va
être le soleil de sa gagne ma fille tu
subis à cause de toi elle se fout du
10au ma fille de suite de recevoir des
trucs comme ça
jégo n'y pas parce que j'ai un talent
qui chante bien s'effacer face il
chantait bien car tu n'es pitch en bien
façon de parler et chant très mal une
bonne mélodie dialyse c'est je pense à
roxane dhr non tu parles de son anxiété
qui parle de de ces problèmes mais qui
super job qui arrive à nantes pied
transparent puis qui est drôle qu'ils
font à suivre puisqu'elle j'apprends les
enfants dans son quotidien
je pense à plein de gens inspirants que
je suis parce que moi je veux être
inspirés de ces personnes indigentes
transparent sert oxame benoît est
approchante hausse de l assuré par une
lettre à mon sujet comment se fait ici
peau si même plus pour son talent jeudi
des alizés could chante bien mais les
paroles aussi à travers ses chances en
pis c'est plein d'affaires de même que
je trouve ça le fun que tu peux suivre
quelqu'un une brillante et ph
j'ai l'impression que j'ai réussi à
avoir une certaine notoriété puisque
c'est le fun t'écouter parce que tu t'es
informe que tu dis pas n'importe quoi
mettez je trouve ça l'fun aussi idéalisé
quelqu'un par tessa tout qu'est ce que
tu fais je faisais sa brillance mais
dans un sens parce que son seul fait
pitié même si une petite fille adore les
vêtements mais son seul fait d'avoir des
références beauté puis de l'iss où il
fut décidé in fact - au kit suis plus un
talent mais là dessus des personnes
vraiment cher qui ont un goût de passer
mon message puis comme dans n'importe
quel métier on a des poux rypien laisse
pas vraiment ce que c'est le sait le la
nuance qui est important de faire puis
d'homme tout un concept que tu que tu
parles relativement souvent ah oui c'est
moi je fonctionne quand même pas mal sur
des personnes que je
j'idéalise comme des héros toi c'est pas
comme ceux qui fonctionnent tout
fonctionne avec en transpirant de la
fusionne aspects de plusieurs personnes
différentes sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya vraiment une possibilité de faire
ce le danger tombe dans de le voir un
petit peu plus de la façon avec laquelle
moi je le vois c'est à dire de prendre
une personne de dire cette personne là
tout ce que cette personne ne l'a fait
je lis des analyses alors que si le
prendre à un aspect de quelqu'un mais je
pense que sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
ultra important parce que parce qu'il
faut être capable de discerner les
choses tu sais pas tout le monde il ya
plein de monde qui ont extrêmement
positif mais qui viennent aussi avec des
deux joueurs faire attention à ce que je
dis mais avec des aspects qui sont
beaucoup moins positifs ou kiss qui ont
peut-être une influence plus négatives
sur surtout la démographie kiki et sur
les réseaux sociaux le stade rennais les
quinzièmes de jongler avec ça mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi que
de suivre quelqu'un puis de s'inspirer
d'un aspect positif
ceci juste sinon mais si ça pis s'il
faut faire attention aussi à ce qu'ont
bien parce que mettons une fois je peux
très reconnu faut se mettant une fois
j'avais reçue au monde du jeu sid ali ce
vraiment pour tâche est jetée comme lot
ouest dans sas nos métiers dans un
espace qui est là à vous voulez être
comme moi nom de cet aspect lot et y en
a qui souhaitait on voit beaucoup de
défis complètement parfaite sur les
réseaux parce que tu veux mais cest une
partie mais ton qui me dérange que je
comprends qu'il ya en eux que si je sais
fakty les réseaux c'est y pas que du
positionnement pas ses portes tant que
du vrai moi j'en vois le 10/10 fille
super positive mais qu'on entend donc
qui ont des boys down this des facs et
pas toujours du vrai et puis ça il faut
faire attention mais quand je demande un
petit pays par exemple juste pour ados
beauté pourquoi tu me suis dit que je
vois que c'est exactement pour qu'est ce
que je veut projeter je trouve ça
complètement malade je pense que
si tout le monde pense de même c'est
cool d'idéaliser quelqu'un sur les
réseaux mais pas de faire tout ce
qu'elle fait parce qu elle parce que
telle et réalise la personne moi j'ai
beaucoup plus comme toi tu m'aimes
encore pire j'idéalise personnes que je
connais pas d'enfer s'agit pas parler
quoi fin de mois je réalise émettant un
membre de ma famille pour ses valeurs
familiales qui sont complètement
incroyable j'idéalise par exemple jazz
de pop en d'horreur qui a un cerveau
d'un master business social s'est
carrément fait que judas liste aei
milliers barrent pour ses talents de
photos complètement cinglé que je sais
je puf agi d'aller des gens pour des des
talents qui ont ou juste j'idéalise
quelqu'un mettons ma mère pour ça sa
gentillesse sa générosité fan moi faut
que je connaisse la personne pour les
dialysés parce que ce pauvre est que je
vais voir qu'est ce que tu fais mais une
fois que les caméras sont éteintes
je te connais pas tu dialyse chose que
je trouve que c'est plus facile demain
parce que je vais parler pour moi peux
tu me dire à ta perception ensuite me
trouve que c'est beaucoup plus facile de
faire cette distinction là en ayant un
petit peu nagé dans cet univers le de
voir à quel point à quel point mettant
quelque chose qui peut paraître ultra
positif mettant une photo que tu vois
sur instagram
comment ça peut paraître ultra positif
puisque en étant un petit peu derrière
surplus en ayant vu un petit peu comment
ça fonctionnait tu réalises que
possiblement que la journée où est cette
photo a été prise c'est pas juste du
positif que ton qui sont faites chier et
qui ont bien enceinte oui mais je
comprends je comprends parfaitement ce
que tu veux dire mais moi j'ai toujours
été de même j'ai été élevé le gazon est
plus vert ailleurs ça sert à rien de
voir ailleurs regarde occupe toi sur ton
gazon puis toi fallait devenir vert puis
je regarde jamais à gand fac
moi j'ai grandi demande était justement
à l'anis au début on parlait que sur
occupation double y avait déjà du storm
qui elle a le voyais vraiment comme
quelqu'un si je ne sais pas comment
comme une colonie ni compte c'est pas
moi j'étais comme voyons il mangea aux
mêmes heures que toi il fallait moins
fort que toi il réussit à être layori
talent c'est certain mais attendons de
penser
deux semaines avec pour me revenir me
voir si il faut qu elle l était beaucoup
plus dans idéalisé puis moi j'ai
toujours été jusqu'à ce que je parle à
quelqu'un je suis incapable de
l'idéalisé mais les réseaux les milieux
où est ce qu'on mange mots à aider à
concrétiser cette pensée le bon sens
soulagé du tarn c'est l'exemple de
personnes qui gît dialyse ou autre que
je peux je dois leur métier qui
j'apprécie encore tellement plus de plus
je connais personnellement parce que je
t'ai georges de trouver un bon animateur
d'occupation double je trouvais drôle
mais quand je rencontrais armstrong et
moi qui ai faim comme acquis et généreux
qui a maquillé tout une inspiration
puis après c'est justement en tout cas
je suis quelqu'un les êtres humains on
est toutes multiples on a dit beaucoup
donné mais moins bon côté betty
justement sa gamme de voir disparaître
valoir qu'elle est plus là dessus
d'autres moins bonnes qui ce taux est
aussi au public de faire les triades
d'orchidées de choisir les bonnes
personnes
josé les bons aspects des bonnes
personnes qui est vite fait c'est ça a
piqué les gens s'en explique
instagram c'est juste le positif mais
moi malheureusement j'ai pas facebook
parce que j'aime pas le négatif plus du
mont chauve que sur facebook tu peux
écrire est de journée n'a pas souri mais
c'est metz au rsa moi je trouve ça beau
qui avait pas de négatif depuis jamais
que ces jeux démos si j'en écoute des
mauvaises journées que je me réveille
piste heureusement qu'on tout mais
jamais je n'en étais je voudrais voyant
affecter les gens explique de saut mais
je suis content de ne pas en voir puis
le je le dis avec ma vie puis je lis
jamais dit mais y'en a qui ce qui sur
instagram
mais dans leur salut beaucoup positif
qui abrite voulons c'est eric losfeld
match com meetic phosphore n'ont jamais
savoir les politiques parce que moi
c'est en voyant aussi pour moi c'est pas
en voyant dispositif que j'ai envie le
positif
au contraire s'il y en a que ils
deviennent en vieux envoyant en étant
sur les réseaux sociaux ils veulent
c'est cheap là ils veulent cette maison
le haut le monde montrent juste le
positif je voyais des jaloux mais je
pense que justement 400 gardes ton gazon
qui te regarde ce que tops tm ce que
tout serait jamais envie faire moi en
voyant du positif chez plus de cette
mentalité le cheval positifs sont fait
du pouce sur ce terrain et qui ont
besoin du malheur des autres
tu sais pas comment des mémoires au
contrat si tout le monde va belges ou
encore mieux le titre est que justement
cette mode la démettre du négatif d'un
transfert je suis comme retirer - devaux
klaus mann s'il vous plaît je l'ait
remarqué ou aussi pis a m'a déçu il m'a
déçu justement parce que c'est comme au
québec
pourquoi le match je me demande pourquoi
tu déposes pareil avec avec tout le
monde sait pourquoi quelque chose c'est
celle de certaines facettes de ta
personnalité tu veux pas la montre n'a
montré que les gens se tuent parce que
parce que d'enfants tous ces noms mais
moi j'ai des amis là les seuls cris
lovren que je vois c'est des amis qui
sont des qui ont des jobs mettons je
pense à des amis qui sont professeurs
puis qui veulent mettre de quoi de faux
ni avec leurs clauses freine c'est
camille vont pas mettre à jour des 15 mm
- moi aussi le petit jeu des chaque fois
de chennevières d'en faire sipa chaque
fois que je passe jours maintenant tu
reçois un commentaire de manger pas
observé jean-marc coppola c'est billie
jean king si ces réseaux sociaux oui le
positivisme aussi le manque de diversité
depuis le de toutes sortes de diversité
que soit corporelle ou culturelles de
quoi que ce soit mais may arnaud il faut
justement là qui suivent c'est parce
qu'ils ne foulent je pense mais c'est ça
mon 6 pts et c'est que moi je comme mara
vice parce que puis l'on va pas entrer
dans le vif du sujet je pense là dedans
on leur faisait un petit aller je pense
était anglaise précise j'ai dit dans ce
sens à temps mais c'est plus que une
fille sur 3 par exemple au deuil des
problèmes alimentaires
ouais
ou en encore en ce moment j'en ai où ça
au mieux mais jamais que je prédis est
aujourd'hui je m'accepte même si je me
vois avec 68 de plus puis je me vois
avec 68 de plus je me dis mais jamais
que je promets une photo de moi maillot
pizza je n'accepte pas ce que tu
voudrais bruissement moins que brahms a
toujours été dans ma taille tandis
qu'oprah fax et je trouve ça plate que
ce soit pas un sujet que je peux aborder
librement parce que j'ai toujours été le
projet mais moins dans ma tête
à ce jour j'ai juste accepter je me
voyais mettons avec 68 de plus
fac se dit le mouvement je le trouve
incroyable mais sur ce plateau de risque
in me faire bâcher si j'en parle à cause
que - qu'est-ce que tu fais dans les
temps morts exactement faso s'est
dissocié vraiment au chellah la
diversité corporelle sur instagram puis
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
extrêmement touch et parce que même si
comme tu dis tenu des troubles
alimentaires ça va bien maintenant mais
que dans ta tête tu as perception de toi
et pas la même que les autres ont de toi
parce que tu fais dans les stands or tu
peux juste pour ça mais j'irai guti gago
higuain joie sauf que sauf que c'est sûr
je pense que je pense que de par le fait
que tu fais dans les stands horse
concentre-toi à parler des choses c'est
son célibat j'aimerais ça dire je te
parles de ton expérience a justement
présenté ses études puis je vais te y en
a tellement lundi je me dis si c'est pas
toutes mes amis c'est presque aucune et
puis des amis plus petit que moi lucky
disant j'y trouve mon ingénieur mais je
suis ça me tape
est ce que tu penses que c'est la
solution mettons pour partager sur ce
serait évidemment
évidemment que si tu prends une photo en
bikini c'est pas c'est pas la solution
l'homme te dis ça c'est pas ma tasse
d'eau non mais admettons de parle parce
que je trouve ça extrêmement intéressant
que quelqu'un qui a l'art de ce que tu
as à vivre ceux de l'intérieur ceci fait
que persuadé que beaucoup de monde dans
ta situation qui gangrènent à entendre
ce discours le fait qu est ce que tu
peux te dire suivait à l'anesthésié
c'est moi c'est elle qui m'a souri des
trous noirs et marne aussi mais je
comprends ce que tu allais pas eu
beaucoup à ce que j'ai fait ce que je
m'en allais en fait c'est juste de dire
mettons des justes sans faire une
publication de toi maillot pour montrer
ton physique juste de prendre la parole
ne serait-ce qu'en story ou dans un lieu
comme ici presque texte tu t'exprimes
sur voici mon expérience ouais
puis c'est comme ça que je le vis gimont
petit j'ai l'impression qu'on a toute
notre sphère people goût nécessairement
de randall ans le fils qui est très très
axée sur ses collègues parce que j'étais
mal commencé explique elle n'a pas parlé
depuis trois ans beau arrive avec ses
pistes la première fois j'en parle parce
qu'après avoir j'en parle mais moi c'est
allant du missouri jeudi à l'ats me
djabel des commentaires que je fais il
était comme s'il se dit plus jamais seul
puis voyons donc ici puis sophie elle le
je m'en foutisme par rapport à ça a
tellement été puissant que l âme le
complètement fait des jeux des facultés
justement il y en eut que c'est comme
qui vont tellement encore mieux le
divulguer moins que c'est correct je
mets toutes celles là je les suis tout
seul qui parle de sa ouvertement toutes
celles qui étaient seules issues pichot
ce magnifique puis justement
oui il devrait en avoir plus mais tu
sais quand on le voit le skull moment on
le voit sauter justement juste l'exemple
dernier souhaitant être aidé elle a pris
la parole là dessus elle s'est fait
ramasser là dessus pas nécessairement
parce qu'elle a pris la parole mais pour
un million d'affaires par rapport à sur
précisément fait que ça c'est sûr que ça
dissuade des gens qui en parlerait de
francs et ceci comme un sujet qui
quittent of a été abordée ouais ouais
mais c'est dans la façon aussi
exactement tout dans la valeur mais moi
c'est pas par peur de critiques
c'est plus parce que je le dise tu sers
bien acheter sa viande est question des
causes puis de choisir c'est qu'en plus
tu te disais tantôt j'ai pas de cause
mais tirs débutent podcasts des mois mon
objectif c'est une série de bonnes notes
dans le fond ce n'est une qualité
puis après ce cas qu'est des choses tu
es maintenant on a parlé brièvement
avant pas de casse pis si on fait des
licols non mais t'es juste maintenant le
mouvement antiraciste en ce moment t on
on est toutes un peu pas mal à l'aise
monde et tout
on sait toutefois comment bien
s'exprimer par rapport à ceux aller dans
un sens dans une étable ça être sentir
hypocrite vous en trois ans les
beaumontois les mots justes pour phi phi
bref mais tout était déjà abordé mais et
si moi je vais à risque harris s'est pas
à risque de me faire bâcher et innocence
ce mouvement là était vraiment ce
mouvement là est vraiment dans l'eau
chaude mois la salle afin que j'ai
retenu puis c'est pour logan qui le dit
puis-je roussat malade c'est que c'est
possible
justement sur ce sujet leur jeu capable
de me prononcer parce que j'ai analysé
j'ai regardé moi je suis sais c'est pas
assez de poids et racistes soient
intéressés il faut que tu prennes la
parole quand quelqu'un dit quoi petit
disent oui on va voyons donc que tu
viennes de penser ce que tu veux dire ça
à bosse a placé sa pauvre rapport vaincu
maintenant et que je vois pas me gêner
pour annoncer les gens qui font des
quelque chose de raciste et que je veux
pas me gêner pis même si c'est un membre
de la famille ou un membre de ma belle
famille où peu importe si quelqu'un dit
quoi tpiy j'espère que les jeunes vont
incapable de commencer leur part
apparemment ce métier je vais des mois
de renault tu es quelqu'un qui a
justement des propos oui bien c'est tout
juste qu'il flirte avec la mangue a
donné le ton le droit de faire ça
faisait vraiment taillé aux vins est ce
que tu as deux copains pas comme ça mais
c'est comme ça donnait le droit avec le
mouvement mitu de kate a joke tout en
fait ouais qui était de la merde je n'ai
jamais dit de précis mais mais qu'est ce
que tu penses plus loin d'être justement
faute activement antiraciste le maître
mais tenter ce qu'attend tout le devoir
de responsabilité la plate forme pour
cette cause le s qui et comment tu deal
avec ce parce que
écoute moi on m'a beaucoup de vie
utilisent la plateforme j'ai mis toutes
qu'est ce que je trouvais complètement
incroyable j'ai signé toutes les
pétitions que j'ai vu passer sans le
mettre sur les réseaux et les compagnies
qui montre qu'on doit encourager j'en ai
suivi beaucoup mais moi c'est beaucoup
plus dans ma vie dans ma vie je vais la
porte et wii sont mes réseaux je dois en
parler c'est sûr en ce moment c'est
important je veux des ces bons ce qui se
passe ça va rester dans l'histoire ce je
suis convaincu mais moi c'est bien plus
dans ma vie vous allez jamais avoir vu
quelqu'un chante pas changé parce que
dis je laisse ça me tient toujours à
l'oreille quand quelqu'un dit jeudi ont
déjà tout entendu le soyons jeudi en
inde j'ai tout entendu samedi à
l'oreille mais quand que sté une forme
d'autorité qui disait ce par exemple je
peux dire ça de tour de taille notoriété
et l'autorité de l'autorité
j'ai fermé ma gueule ouais mais si moi
je fais mayol puis la personne concernée
femmes seules qui va parler pourrait le
faire maintenant je vais avoir le droit
de la regarder peser ben voyons tous et
je diffusais main à faire de même face
moi c'est plus dans ma vie que je vois
la porte et dans les compagnies pitié je
pense que si chacun fasse un pas en
notre génération va être king cole hier
je suis allée courir puis je cours quand
même longtemps puis j'ai décidé de
découvrir pilote de repenser toute ma
vie ou du moins ce qui me venait en tête
au moment où est ce que il y aurait eu
un un moment où est ce que ce soit moi
qui avais fait une job qui avait pas de
sens où que ce soit quelque chose que
j'avais véhicule où que j'aille entendu
puis de me manger avec eux aujourd'hui
ça se reproduisait mai soit six témoins
jamais qui gère frais enjoy comme ça ou
que je dire à quelqu'un et mène ce ça
passe pas il y est j'ai passé deux
heures de course a juste penser à se
retrouver iman sont vraiment nuls sans
arrêt ça mais moi c'est ça c'est parfait
puis justement tu veux plus jamais moi
je pense qu est grâce à ce beau petit
toutes ces belles images la faune
complètement incroyable mais j'espère
qu'à chaque personne va penser comme
nous même si sur la faute et moi ça m'a
toujours
ça m'a toujours dérangé parce que j'ai
jamais compris ceux ci pour être honnête
j'ai jamais ici ce qui m'agace c'est que
moi je sais maintenant j'ai reçu 2 10 m
torcy lance montre que peace et d'yves
sasp afin qu'à partir de logements moi
j'ai pris trois jours là pour tout lire
tout réfléchi puis après être activée je
n'ai pas mais ce n'est pas tout cas je
n'ai pas dire n'importe quoi mais chaque
fois samedi réagir puis maintenant je
sais que je peux dire c'est justement
maintenant je veux rentrer dans personne
n'a quand même eu tôt fait exactement ce
qu'il fallait faire jouer la première
chose à faire en ce moment c'est la
réflexion le puits c'est la réflexion
c'est qu'il parle trop vite peut-être
qu'ils s'y est déjà si c'est déjà réglé
pour régler mais celui-ci est déjà
pensée qui saperait qui sans correct de
dire ce qu'il ya des fins mairie je
reçois tellement pas mieux
quelqu'un qui ont mis plein plein plein
plein de belles images à la seconde que
ç'a été puis s'est mis à parler de 200
malades comme si c'était ça ch'ti jeudi
en entrevue le s'improviser s'improvise
pas papy que prochaine fois qu'ils
revendent à quoi ils disaient ouais je
faisais ça va j'ai vu c'est que ça c'est
que ça soit long terme
oui c'est que le changement soit long
terme fakty si c'est juste une traîne en
la parole aux femmes c'est fini c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aux tic ou mieux
prendre son temps m'est très cher pour
vraiment manqué sa chance mais j j'ai
jamais autant pris conscience de quelque
chose que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde pour qui celle que
puis c'est au delà de ses six essais
dans le concept d'être activement
antiraciste dit le concept de revoir au
complet notre système puis la
conversation qu'ont eue avec webster à
travers ce moi ça me fait prendre
conscience de commandes même si on se
considère pas raciste de commencer loin
dans le dans le système dans lequel on
est puis de coma pour déconstruire c'est
faux que individuellement à chaque
moment où est-ce qu'on a une décision à
prendre qu'on soit conscient que ce soit
pas nécessairement de coliques quelqu'un
qui fait un job ça c'est évident tout le
monde mais il ya beaucoup de monde qui
vont faire ça mais c'est maintenant ok
tête un président de compagnie vient le
temps d'engager qui tangage
vers qui tu diriges des offres d'emplois
verts qui tu veux offrir une opportunité
égale by cc oui tout ça on commence à
penser les parents leurs enfants le
jeudi c'est important de l'éducation
puis de lille
parce que à l'école cela doit cesser de
mode c'est de montrer le tilly s'est
vertement tin whistle est l'exemple qui
disait je partais un mohamed version 5 %
est évident mohammed vi dungy je ne
traite pas de la même façon même si les
compétences ce qui est écrit dessus
pareil si c'est démontrer le chiffre
là-dessus 1 c'est fou vexés les
responsables de tout le monde ce soir -
même si même si il y en a qui le font
parce que c'est un trend au moins cette
réflexion le j'ose croire qu est votre
demeurer même qu'elle demeure le minimum
dans une personne ce sera au moins ce
qui reste c'est parce que il y en a pour
plein d'autres qui vont qui vont ça va
rester plus présents puis à ma matin
j'entendais ashton kutcher qui est fait
une vidéo hier sur twitter elle qui m'a
vraiment fait réfléchir pays dit qu'en
cas qu'on dit blake lively mardi que du
monde qui disent qu'ils s'élèvent pour
nom c'est en live madoff lui dit si jean
l'ofs faut faut les éduquer et non les
marginaliser il dit parce que on
s'entend tous que toutes les vies
maturité il dit mais pourquoi est ce que
nous on dit en live marketplace donne là
il donne l'exemple avec avec avec sa
petite fille
ou est ce qu ils vont lire une histoire
à sa petite fille perd son petit groupe
c'est la petite fille qui va en premier
que le petit gain lundi pour cause pour
moi en premier puis lâche un coach le
dit parce que c'est l'effet en premier
club se dit pourquoi est-il parce que
pour nous c'est l'effet en premier parce
qu'il ya du monde dans vie pour qui les
faits ils vont juste pas c'est pour qui
les faits ils peuvent jamais y aller
p10 pourquoi est ce que nous c'est black
light demandeurs en ce moment c'est
parce qu'il y en a pour qui blige john
mayer feig une fois une fois c'est de
réaliser que on a le devoir de mettre de
l'avant puis au moins six essais
qui est qui en ressort du trend parce
que moi aussi je suis ambivalent avec
avec le traîne depuis avec l'idée que
les gens embarquent dans quelque chose
parce que c'est rennes dit et on le vit
le 24.4 millions de corps et noir publié
sur facebook sur instagram jeu mardi le
tir puisque je pense que la comparaison
c'était comme 11 millions de signatures
à sa pétition pour la justice pour
georges floride le tchèque
sentant que deux poids deux mesures sur
celle là mais même si c'est ça un
gasquet au moins la personne qui a posté
encore et noir va y avoir pensé
et puis la personne qui ait pas pensé la
journée des cordes et noir et il ya
toujours des critiques va pas assumer
aujourd'hui corinne ouest n'avait jamais
passé
t'as pas le choix tu avais le nez dessus
puis je lisais ce matin new york
c'est en ce moment l'hypothèse qu'ils
aient eu lieu dans 50 états américains y
en eut d'ange pas comme une pays
mais quand combiné ça c'est le plus
grand mouvement
si si vraiment d'une ampleur incroyable
tpiy bella ou pour nous je trouve que la
ligne difficile à combler joselyne ligne
c'est l'équilibré entre écoute et
laisser la parole à ce qui est vraiment
pertinente pu aussi parler parce que
pour que les gens proches de nous
l'entente et puis c'est ce parce qu'il
ira t on ou de la table de saint paul
mais moi je l'aï invitée in une
expérience je parle apparemment des
podcasts en pensant ce qui aussi je
comprends je pourrais jamais le dire
mieux que mais tout qu'est-ce que je
partage le pense à 200%
enfin je pense qu'en ce moment c'est bon
de soutenir mais c'est son sens en
parler de personne d'autre
moi je préfère partager qu'est ce que je
trouve complètement bon de des experts
des gens qui ont parlé puisque ça va
être ma façon de parler à travailler
initiative que je trouve vraiment
intéressante qui je prendrai des mets de
la pression ou là qui se joue pas mais
c'est prête à plateforme à quelqu'un et
mettons soit un artiste noir besoin un
militant droit ou soir à quelqu'un qui a
quelque chose départ qui touche quelque
chose de renverser un doute qui doit
être entendue plus mettons pendant une
journée pendant un temps x tu prêtes de
plate forme d'un message à travers toile
tout attribut entier sochaux c'est
vraiment un coup oui c'est vrai l'autre
truc qui est difficile à jongler avec
cette ligne c'est j'entendais un podcast
ses perfs line coacher trois entraîneurs
bas ces deux entraîneurs un lieu de la
nba ingles de la nfl puis là il recevait
un autre gars de la nba fait que ces
trois hommes blancs en haut de 50 ans
les occupants de cette situation-là
actuelle puis au début du podcast 10 on
est trois hommes blancs en haut de 50
ans puis on parle à des hommes blancs en
haut de 52 pays dits en ce moment faut
vous rejoignent les hommes blancs aux 50
ans parce que vous suivez sûrement pas
les activistes noir sur instagram vous
vous écoutez ce que vous consommez on
est en train de le produire
c'est important de vous parler de tout
ceci fait que de parler à leur tribune
qui autrement iront pas justement
nécessairement consommer les autres
choses c'est que c'est comme l'autre pan
du truc de dire oui ok prêtre t'avoir
partage c'est parce que ce soit que
c'est bien de partager des plateformes
et admettons qu'on considère je te
prendre un exemple encore une fois il y
a je me prends deux mois ça va être
simple moi mettons un plateforme 120
mille abonnés sur instagram
même si je redirige vers 1
un compte d'un activiste combien que
voir des montres compliquées sont
compétents dans les bonnes journées j'ai
pas aimé il puisse si moi je prends la
parole il ya crissement plus de monde
qui vont l'entendre ces faits qui aussi
cette question là de dire oui je
comprends mais le monde qui veulent pas
entendre le monde qui veulent qu'ils me
suivent - mettons ils veulent pas
nécessairement entendre quelqu'un
d'autre part les de ce fait qu'il ya
quand même cette espèce de petite nuance
la fin on a une tribune certes prêter
notre tribune ça peut être une bonne
idée de comme essayer de de forcer une
opinion autre que la nôtre à notre
auditoire et c'est plus que derrière
défense
non mais c'est ce que je te dise non
mais non mais c'est un peu forcé de dire
de passer de mon compte instagram
exactement c'est se fixer des limites on
clique sur ma phase productive
historique c'est pas moi qui parle c'est
un peu forcer quelqu'un à écouter
quelque chose quelqu'un d'autre que
monastique appelons la comme on le veut
mais c'est un petit peu ce fait on a
quand même la responsabilité de
s'adresser à notre auditoire fake de
garder le silence complet de juste
redirigée des gens je ne sais pas je
sais c'est off pour moi de comprendre
c'est difficile c'est difficile de voir
ce celle de savoir la bonne chose à
faire parce que c'est mettons justement
le black-out youth daily
c'est beaucoup de gens sont d'abord qui
dans le mouvement
cet existant parce qu'il a écrit mme
quelque chose qui supporte la pression
était le contre le mouvement des gens ne
sont pas d'accord et dans tous ses
mouvements lucky dube l'a7 eu la parole
des gens qui ont vraiment besoin d'être
entendu il en a fait qu il ya de toutes
les choses que tu vas faire y voir des
gens qui vont être pauvre on a travaillé
au sein de toutes les communautés la
communauté noire pense pas te paraît non
plus ça il ya des gens qui vont être
prises contre ceux d'accor est ce que tu
fais par là qu est ce que tu fais à
mener 6 2 réfléchit puis pas la chose
que toute dépense qui a sachant qu'il
faudra qu'il skie pas quelqu'un qui ait
pas d'accord et des bonnes chances
c'est une question qui tâche et surtout
surtout quand qu'on passait d'une
tribune
on peut pas rester muet je suis d'accord
qu'on peut pas rester muet maintenant
comment tu prends la parole est ce que
tu la prend au risque de se tromper est
ce que tu vas prendre aux autres clément
est ce que la raison c'est pourquoi j'ai
pas parlé parce que j'aime pas parler de
quelque chose que je me concentre pas
qualifié moi c'est beaucoup plus sauf
moi je me suis reculé pour m'informer
beaucoup puis même là encore dommage
j'écoute je pourrais regarder mon celle
là je dois avoir 50 vidéos de moi qui
parle
puis je les ai jamais eues pop j'ai déjà
même que j'ai envoyé achiary j'ai envoyé
à mon père j'ai envoyé un gentil tu
penses quoi toi succès puis m'ont tous
dit
4 ces malades melli ce port j -p
je suppose je veux juste pas mais pro
visé promettant je sais qu'il faut en
parler mais j'avais pas vu la perception
de les gens veulent l'écouter toi mais
tu es même mois le nombre de fois que je
parle à ma caméra c'est vraiment peu si
je préfère montrer que me fini à globe
me lancer dans le sujet par l'éditeur il
coûte cette offre c'est un john bitove
puis y'a personne je veux dire si t'es
pas à l'aise de le faire t'es pas la
seule fois je parlais de mégi good
comprend ouais c'est ça la face c'est là
que c'est là qu'ils arrivent dans
l'ambiguïté puis écoute ça fait pas
longtemps que je voudrais pas pour
longtemps que ça arrive pour longtemps
qu'on y réfléchisse mais au moins c'est
pas des pistes de réflexion puis à
chaque jour la situation change l'été
puis c'est fou comment peut-être pour
faire un cercle complet jusqu'à jusqu'au
début du podcast le c'est fou comme 1 là
la situation actuelle tout remis en
perspective pis comment les derniers
jours ont été un flux constant de
déséquilibre de 2020 sur l'année de
remise en question révaluation de tout
simplement ce métier si ça tu peux le
voir de deux façons ne peut voir que
tout va mal il peut voir aussi que c'est
l'année de la remise en question sont
tous très questionné piffard du
changement pour que ce soit mieux pis
thank god les réseaux sociaux sont leurs
parce que les hanches harlem est long le
vu le avec le co vide comme un clin voir
l'information s'est propagée met ko 6e
10 mouvement complètement ma pour
les centres hospitaliers puis que l'on a
en ce moment le mouvement puis moi je le
prononce pas parce que black lips
mas2zik l'âge c'est juste parce que mon
anglais pourquoi pas que des amateurs
mais c'est mon anglais mais juste leur
devoir justement le 24 millions je le
savais pas mais c'est hallucinant c'est
de montrer l on y tient on le change
ensemble ils les réseaux même si on est
confiné à maison on ne réalisait que les
réseaus la plus belle plate forme
puisque maintenant avec un thé à un clic
de voir qu'est ce que tu désires voix on
chauffe beaucoup mieux la télé sinon
seraient pas dans ce mouvement
planétaire le s'il n'y avait pas eu une
vidéo qui avait été filmée qui avait été
partagée ces réseaux sociaux je vous
avais ça se passe depuis toujours
la salle a été filmée pilot le monde
sait ça c'est demain le fameux el
racisme devient pape y redevient film et
moi c'est ça ouais quand même
on est plus à huawei sur ses bras
merci infiniment à est venu c'était
vraiment super intéressant merci à vous
vraiment merci pour les belles
discussions ont séduit à continuer à
partager le bonheur
ouais